jeff guin former book editor for the
fort worth star telegram presents a
history of the infamous couple bonnie
parker and clyde barrow
mr gwynne contends that bonnie and clyde
were inept crooks throughout their
two-year crime spree
the event hosted by the kansas city
public library in kansas city missouri
is 40 minutes
thanks to everybody for coming out
tonight and
because you've gone to a lot of trouble
it's cold out it's starting to rain
and you're all hoping i'll talk fast so
you can get home and watch missouri
get into the elite eight
and i think they will
so to start this evening off you know
you've just seen a movie that that's
magnificent entertainment and has become
part of american lore
to write a book about bonnie and clyde
is to enter into great controversy you
know there's so many theories so many
rumors
and so let's start tonight by laying
the worst most vile
and untrue rumor to rest
i am not the twin brother of warren
beatty
i give all warren a lot of credit
he made a heck of a movie
and it's brilliant and i like watching
it i'm sure you do too
the fact remains that it simply extended
the mythology
of a story that at its root
tells us an awful lot
not just about who
two poor kids from west allis were
but the way our culture
quite often rewrites history to fit
what we want to believe or at a certain
time
we need to believe
it's true that i didn't intend to write
this book books are like children they
grow up to be whatever they want to be
you don't have much control over it my
original plan was to write a book
called along the tall tale trail i was
going to drive around america
i was going to go to places iconic
places in our country or places where
people who become a huge part of our
culture were reputed to have done some
things that perhaps they hadn't done
and i thought i'd start by going to west
allis i live in fort worth bonnie and
clyde grew up in west allis i figure
it's a short drive and if i didn't
really find them interesting i hadn't
wasted my time
after only a couple days
i called my editor simon schuster and i
said that this has to be a book
about bonnie and clyde
because i was learning things that
staggered me
things that i had never imagined before
i imagine some of you out here tonight
are bonnie and clyde long time scholars
we have jim spahn for instance who's
done some wonderful things
involving studying the platte city
shootout
we all know platte city it's the garden
spot just outside kansas city where your
airport
is now located
and it's also where bonnie and clyde
and their criminal career
began to be extinguished that was the
beginning of the end
the thing that i thought needed to be
done in this book
there have been to my knowledge 27
previous books written about bonnie and
clyde that come from
reputable publishers there's probably
three times that many self-published
and i've read everyone i can get my
hands on but very few have context
and by that i mean this
the great historian stephen ambrose used
to say that he wrote books to answer one
question
and that question was
how did they do that
and whether steve ambrose was writing
about the transcontinental railroad or
organizing d-day
the purpose of his books the thing he
wanted to find out was how was it done
go down together is my 14th book and in
my books i try to answer a question too
but it's a different one
what i always want to understand
is
why
did they do that
and that's where context comes in
and in the case of bonnie and clyde and
the legend that's grown and been
refurbished and reshaped and 75 years
after they're dead it's still going on
it seems to me there's two why's to be
answered the first is
why did two kids
from a terrible slum
who were among the most incompetent
thieves that ever pulled a gun and said
stick em up
who were the antithesis
of glamour
why did they choose quite knowingly
to embark on a life of crime
that would bring them fleeting fame but
had to inevitably end with their violent
deaths they knew this was coming they
expected it
yet they were willing
to have this happen why
and then the second question
why did america
embrace
bonnie and clyde
why did they become national icons
following in the footsteps not just of
billy the kid and jesse james
but charles lindbergh
babe ruth
jack dempsey
why did that happen
so there's two parts to the book if we
understand them if we understand where
they came from
maybe we start to understand the rest
clyde barrow and bonnie parker were
products
of a place called west dallas
that was a hell hole
outside of the city of dallas
the dallas
power brokers
very much wanted to create a city that
rivaled san francisco for for great
culture
they didn't want riff raff
and riffraff was exactly what henry
barrow clyde's father was when he
arrived in 1922 with his wife cumie
his three youngest children clyde lc and
marie
looking for work because they'd failed
as tenant farmers
the barrows lived in west dallas
not just in a slum
but in a tent city that was built in a
marshy piece of land
just on the west side of the trinity
river
it was pestilential
adults and children died regularly from
all kinds of diseases that they caught
the the people who were luckiest
lived in tents there the barrows
couldn't afford a tent
they slept underneath the wagon that
they rode in on
food
where sandwiches made what were called
then west dallas round steak which means
bologna and when there wasn't bologna
people were fed stale bread
on holidays children were given oranges
those were the only christmas presents
the barrow kids ever got
they were born in a time
when a man
stayed in the economic level where he
was born if you were born poor white
trash you pretty much stayed there
and clyde barrow was an ambitious kid he
was a fine gifted musician he played the
guitar in the saxophone
his sister already used to say that her
idea of heaven was listening to clyde
play melancholy baby
he quit school when he was 16 and did
what kids and
of his upbringing did he went to work in
a west dallas factory
for a dollar a day
and realize that was it
he could look across the trinity river
and you'd have those gleaming
skyscrapers of dallas
if he could scare up a dime he could go
to a movie and he could see people
wearing fancy clothes and driving
beautiful cars
like every other kid in west allis he
wanted to wear sunday clothes all during
the week
clyde was something of a ladies man he
liked to date girls the girl's parents
wouldn't let them go out with trash like
clyde
even other west dallas families looked
down on the barrows
because
henry barrow was a trashman the barrows
were the lowest of the low
and that was the life of clyde barrow
when he decided that he would supplement
his income first he started stealing
chickens
then he graduated to cars
clyde barrow was a bumbling bank robber
but that boy could steal a car like
nobody's business
in those days a ford would cost you 260
dollars brand new if clyde could steal
one and sell it on the black market he
might make a hundred dollars this is in
the depression that's good money so
there's clyde barrow
bonnie elizabeth parker
born in rowena texas a little west texas
town her mother emma parker
is a social climber like you wouldn't
believe i'm sure in kansas city society
there are no ladies who are determined
that their families will be
the blue bloodedest of them all
but emma parker was going to make that
happen and here's why rowena was a
farming community
the husbands of all the other ladies who
brought their children and husband to
the baptist church every sunday were
farmers
bonnie's father was a brick mason the
way emma saw it that made them royalty
and she raised her little girl to
believe that
bonnie's first mark that she ever made
was made when she was three years old
when a tent revival meeting came to
rowena and some of the little children
of rowena were invited on stage to sing
their favorite
hymns and bonnie got right up there
raised her eyes to the lord and sang the
honky tonk tune he's a devil in his own
hometown
she got a standing ovation
from that moment bonnie's expressed
desire in life was to be one of two
things she was either going to be an
actress on broadway
or she was going to be one of those
ubiquitous world famous millionaire
poets
she wrote a lot of poetry when we look
at it now we see that she had a
stuttering sense of rhythm but she loved
quotation marks she used them every
other word
so bonnie's going to be royalty and
little rowena except something bad
happens her father dies unexpectedly
when she is three years old
though some people said he got sick and
tired of emma and simply ran off we
don't know for sure but emma parker has
to move with her three young children to
west dallas to live with her parents and
there the parker family now descends
into poverty
emma gets a job sewing overalls her pay
was about seven dollars a week
and bonnie elizabeth parker
a bright young woman faces this folks
if she stays in high school and
graduates it makes no difference there's
no money for college and for poor girls
in west dallas these were your career
choices
you could sling hash
you could work as a maid or you could be
a prostitute those were basically the
things bonnie had to choose among
she went for choice number four
when bonnie was 15 years old she married
a man named roy thornton
who was just a few years older than her
bonnie believed in the movie romances
that she'd go see at the bijou
and she thought at least if she married
roy she would have a lifetime of poverty
but of true love except it didn't work
out that way
he beat her continually he disappeared
for weeks on end he finally deserted her
she never divorced him
if faye dunaway wasn't wearing a wedding
ring in that scene you just saw
then that was a mistake because bonnie
parker wore roy thornton's wedding ring
for the rest of her life
she was working as a waitress when roy
left her
there's a very strong possibility she
was occasionally turning tricks and she
was not doing this to be promiscuous she
was doing it to be able to feed herself
and her family
and then 1930 january there's a party in
west allis
clyde barrow and bonnie parker both get
there they see each other that's it
everything else about them has been
exaggerated or downright fictionalized
they were not great crooks they were not
glamorous
but they loved each other it was a real
love story
they were instantly attracted and
because of that they they were
inseparable until three weeks later when
clyde was arrested bonnie's house for
car theft and ended up being sentenced
to 14 years in prison in texas
clyde barrow
is 22 years old he is sent to easton
prison farm which is a hell hole
prisoners there are treated like slaves
worked until they dropped and it is in
prison that clyde barrow kills his first
man
ed crowder a prison trustee who had been
raping clyde in prison for almost a year
caved his head in with a pipe
not long after that clyde who didn't
think he would survive working in those
fields for 14 years
did something a lot of other convicts
there would do eastham was called the
bloody ham because to get out of that
back breaking killing field work
convicts would routinely take a hoe or
an x and cut off their own hands or feet
clyde barrow cut off
his big left toe and part of another toe
on his left foot and he was crippled for
the rest of his life and limped badly
this will tell you something about clyde
barrow
he did that on a monday
on tuesday he found out that his mother
had gotten him pardoned by the governor
and he was able to go home
he limps back to dallas
meets bonnie again
makes lots of noises about going
straight but it doesn't work out that
way in those days a man could be
arrested for suspicion by the police
just because they thought you might have
done something and hauled into jail for
questioning
the dallas police didn't want a bad guy
like clyde barrow back stealing cars so
they would make a habit of pulling him
in just about every day
they'd take him downtown interrogate him
let him go and he'd have to walk back
four or five miles to west dallas
wherever he was working and usually he
would come back to get fired
we were lucky enough in writing this
book to have access to two unpublished
manuscripts from clyde's family his
mother cumie and his sister marie
so we know from them that clyde decided
why bother going straight it wasn't
going to work he and bonnie decided to
embark on a life of crime they hated the
way their lives were
they knew
inevitably they were going to come to a
bad end
but
they thought it was worth it
i won't i won't regale you now with the
stories of what awful thieves they were
suffice it to say for their first big
job
they ended up getting their getaway car
stuck in the mud they tried to escape
riding mules bareback
they got pitched into the mud they got
surrounded by angry townspeople
clyde left bonnie there ran away
bonnie was arrested and held in prison
for three months until a grand jury
decided she was just some silly girl who
was senselessly in love and had gotten
pulled into sin and they released her
it's it would almost be slapstick comedy
except for one thing
people died
bonnie and clyde came from horrible
backgrounds but please understand me
there is no excuse for what they did
there were lots of poor kids who aspired
to great things and didn't try to get
them by robbing and in the case of the
barrow gang they've been accused of as
many as 17 murders by my count 11 people
died at their hands
and
almost every case it happened because
they got themselves in stupid situations
the gang tried to shoot their way out in
panic and innocent people died it was
wrong they did these things
and yet look where they were coming from
why did they get famous then why did
america embrace them
it's because inadvertently accidentally
their timing was perfect
it's the depths of the depression now i
want you to try to imagine something
today that's almost impossible okay
it's a terrible recession
in 1932
people barely have money for rent
what they want is they want some kind of
entertainment to get their minds off
their problems and the the industry that
everyone believed was going to disappear
was newspapers
can you imagine a time when people were
not subscribing to newspapers anymore it
boggles the mind
but that was happening
the media
wanted some kind of stories they could
print that would make people keep buying
newspapers
the public wanted entertainment
they the only thing going successfully
were the talkies the new movies and
jimmy cagney blasting people with a
machine gun
and again try to imagine a time where
people thought the banks were the enemy
i don't know if you can
but if it's possible work with me here
so in texas at first
parts of oklahoma new mexico the papers
start writing about the will of the wisp
bandit
clyde barrow who can disappear like
smoke and
the glamorous young woman at his side
and it worked okay until
the day in a place called joplin
in west texas the lake if kids had a
nickel
one of their big in west allis rather
one of their big treats was to go to
fair park in dallas
where you could get three pictures a
strip of three pictures for a nickel
and the kids would pose the girls would
wear these goofy hats and have parasols
and the boys would point those droopy
rubber guns where you know the barrel
would sort of point down at the ground
instead
clyde and bonnie used to love that and
when they're out as real criminals in
the world
they kept posing for these funny
pictures just like they did back in west
allis only now they had real guns
one day
in spring in 1933 bonnie did
just a salacious thing the barrels were
traveling with a real criminal
mastermind named w.d jones
wd was 16
and he was such a cold-blooded thug that
he was afraid of the dark
and at night would insist on sleeping
with bonnie and clyde so the boogeyman
wouldn't get him and that is absolutely
true
to look like a big man
wd tried smoking cigars
big stogies that stuck about a foot out
of his mouth we're assuming he probably
coughed a lot when he tried to inhale we
weren't there we can only assume
but bonnie one day just for fun
put her leg up on the bumper of a car in
a rather unladylike pose dangled a
pistol from her hand stuck a cigar
between her lips wd took the picture and
they forgot about it
a few months later the gang is renting
an apartment in joplin missouri
where they do their usual dumb thing of
calling attention to themselves
unnecessarily in theory they're hiding
out and having a vacation but they keep
parking a series of new fancy stolen
cars in front
they come and go at all hours of the
night one day clyde's cleaning the
browning automatic rifles accidentally
pulls the trigger and fires a burst into
the next house
i guess they thought the neighbors
wouldn't notice
well the neighbors called the joplin
police who immediately came to the
conclusion there must be some
bootleggers at work maybe car thieves
and they put together a posse with
minimal planning tried to surround the
place and in fact clyde and bonnie and
wd clyde's brother buck and his
sister-in-law blanche got away
two officers were killed in the process
and when the police went into the
apartment they found a lot of belongings
and possessions that the gang had left
behind including an undeveloped roll of
film
they got it developed and there was the
picture
if clyde were here right now he'd be
firing a burst of the browning automatic
rifle
but he'd
miss and kill other innocent spectators
thank god he isn't here
in that this film there was one picture
above all
this is how perfect bonnie and clyde's
timing was
there was something newfangled that had
just been started called the wire
services
where a picture could run in a newspaper
one day and be in every other newspaper
in the country the next and that picture
of bonnie with the cigar hanging out of
her mouth
was transmitted nationwide
now readers may have not known what the
term freudian implication meant but they
got it anyway
within days
the barrow gang had evolved from
regional rumor
to national icon
and they were embraced
country loved them
couldn't get enough of him and the media
played to that by publishing all kinds
of stories if they were rumored to have
been anywhere that story ran as fact
and on it went but not too long there's
a reason for that
in platte city not far from here the
beginning of the end came when for the
first time law officers led by a great
man a great lawman named holt coffey
actually went in properly armed
surrounded the baro gang
they should have been caught right there
they were trapped at the red crown
tavern
except
an armored car man driving an armored
car which was actually a regular car
with some armor plating was supposed to
be blocking a driveway
and he suffered a slight wound panicked
and backed out that gave clyde a chance
to drive free otherwise all the things
frank hamer that never would have
happened
bonnie and clyde somehow i think deeply
believed that they'd they lived this
long evaded that many lawmen because
they were criminal masterminds nothing
could be further from the truth
most local lawmen were farmers or good
old local boys who needed a job got
elected were paid 15 a week they had to
supply their own guns
usually 22 pistols that they shot
varmints with and their own cars often
farm trucks held together by bailing
wire
clyde may have been a lousy crook
but he stole wonderful cars took great
pride in only stealing ford v8s
broke into national guard armories and
had browning automatic rifles so usually
when there was uncoordinated pursuit
they could drive away away from it and
if they couldn't do that they could
shoot their way out of it
halt coffee basically
wrote the game plan for how to take them
down
and it was ultimately taken up by the
most famous texas ranger of all frank
hamer
in the end of january
1934.
hamer was a famous texas ranger who at
the time he agreed to come after bonnie
and clyde was already credited with
killing over 50 criminals being wounded
17 times himself
he was such a folk hero that his gun had
a nickname his sidearm he called his
pistol old lucky
and he was hired to find bonnie and
clyde and put them in the ground hamer
always told his troops the best way to
enforce the law is a bullet in the gut
and basically that's what he did
there's been controversy since whether
henry methvin's family the last member
of the barrow gang set up bonnie and
clyde whether the methans were coerced
against their will we got very lucky in
this project by finding a man who in the
1970s had made a number of videotape
interviews with the methvin family so we
now know what happened
on may the 23rd 1934 six lawmen set up
an ambush for bonnie and clyde who had
been tricked into coming that way by
henry methvin and his family
the lawman fired 160 shots
clyde died instantly
the whole thing took 16 seconds after
clyde died bonnie had just enough time
to see what was going to happen she
screamed she died and as ted hinton one
of the dallas deputies involved in the
ambush said later when we were done they
were nothing but a pile of wet rags
and yet
they were even more popular in death
than in life ten thousand people
attended clyde's funeral twenty thousand
bodies and they bragged bonnie's family
that the dallas news boys chipped in 100
bucks to buy a big bouquet of flowers
for her casket and thanks for all the
extra copies of the newspapers the
barrow gang had sold for them
true crime magazines kept the legend
going for years after that
1966
blanche barrow
having served her jail sentence
is at home in the little dallas suburb
of segoville a man knocks on her door
says his name's warren beatty
wants to do a movie about bonnie and
clyde all the other main characters are
dead she's the only one living he would
like to pay her for the use of her name
blanche is excited she gets enough money
to build a fence around her property
warren beatty shows her script and tells
her about the wonderful actors who are
going to be in the cast
and blanche who
forget the movie was one heck of a
beauty in her day got the idea that this
gorgeous gal named faye dunaway
was maybe going to play her
couldn't wait to see the movie
the premiere comes blanche struts in
she watches the movie
the movie is over
blanche stands up
and announces
that movie made me look like a screaming
horse's ass
let's face it she was right
everybody in the barrel in the parker
families tried to sue the studio judge
threw out all their lawsuits said that
everybody was dead couldn't do that but
frank hamer's widow won a large
settlement because the movie of course
tried to make it look as though hamer
had a grudge against the barrow gang
because it made him look so foolish when
in fact hamer never even saw bonnie and
clyde until the day he killed them
so here we are 75 years later
the image burnishing continues there's
going to be a new bonnie and clyde movie
a remake
and i understand that that great
talented serious actress named hilary
duff is going to play bonnie
i have i have heard from someone
involved in the production
read my book i guess they wanted to ask
me a few questions
i said well i hope this book is really
going to stick to the history i think
that'll that'll really sell a lot of
popcorn people will be interested and
they said here's the thing
we're going to have a surprise ending
yep
so here's the thing why do we write
books about history
i think
our purpose ought to be
to have some record
of what really happened
that's why i love to read about history
as well as to write about it something
that answers the questions why did these
things happen
i don't claim that this book is going to
ever be the definitive book because when
you're writing about history no book is
definitive
it has some new things in it someday
someone else is going to come along and
find something i missed and maybe build
on it i sure hope so jim spahn's going
to be doing a book soon i can't wait to
read it it's going to be wonderful
but we've got to try
when you write history and you weren't
there
basically what you're trying to do is
make the best educated guesses you can
if you read my book i hope you'll notice
there's 55 pages of chapter notes
every time i say i believe this happened
i want you to know why
beyond that when you read the book i
hope you'll think about this
could bonnie and clyde be an excellent
example
of how
in our different times of trouble
we invent
things that perhaps did not quite exist
we make people become what they want
what we want them to be and not who they
were
i think we can learn a lot about
ourselves from what happened with bonnie
and clyde
and meanwhile
the story goes on they'll continue
to interest us to obsess some of us
that may not be a bad thing if we learn
from some of the mistakes they made
and some of the reasons we created some
of the exaggerations
that we wove what i'd like to do maybe
there's some folks out there that would
like to ask a question or two uh
this looks like a great crowd and uh
this is i've been out two weeks and i
would like to say i would like to be
able to tell my wife when i get home
tomorrow i got the best questions in
kansas city you don't want me saying it
was minneapolis uh we're setting up some
microphones here so if you've got a
question why don't you come on up to the
microphone so that everybody can hear
you
yes sir
i was wondering why
they called it platt city iowa
because they were damn fools thank you
next
yes sir hi
i was curious on black blanche barrel
because i remember when i saw the movie
um years ago
you know you just saw where she was in
the hospital and then she just kind of
dropped off the face of the earth can
you do you know a little bit about what
happened to her and then was she also a
consultant since she was the only
surviving
person to that movie bombing
blanche
uh wrote a very obscure memoir that's
wonderful
called my life with bonnie and clyde and
if you can find a used copy you ought to
see it
after
platte city
not iowa
buck had been shot the barrows fled to
iowa where they were surrounded again
and captured
buck died and blanche was brought back
to stand trial for
shooting a firearm during platte city
which blanche always swore she didn't do
she got 10 years a sentence of 10 years
in prison
she served her time came back to texas
remarried
and was a heck of a beer drinking old
lady who
was known after she'd had a six-pack or
two
to start talking about how bonnie was
jealous because blanche was prettier and
it could have been true
she sold the rights to use her name to
the movie but i promise you if she had
been a consultant in the movie faye
dunaway would have played her
blanche did not appreciate the movie
and in her later years you did not want
to mention it around her after she'd had
a brew or two
uh what else was there really a letter
to henry ford
you know one of everybody's favorite
stories about clyde because he'd only
steal ford vhs is that he wrote henry
ford a letter saying you know yours are
the best and while i've got breath in me
i want to thank you
there's one little problem with that
the letter was signed clyde champion
barrow
clyde's name was clyde chestnut barrow
and his family always swore and they
were probably right that he would not
have put a different name there but i
will say that henry ford thought the
letter was real
he wrote clyde a thank you note
and sent it to general delivery in tulsa
where clyde's letter had been postmarked
so henry ford i'm sure to his last
breath was going boy the that barrel boy
may have been a killer but he had great
manners and great taste in cars
yes sir
yeah i remember
when they used to tour
some of the state fairs and stuff you'd
bring
that car around
well there were actually three cars
making the rounds as the real death car
the real real death car currently is
owned by a casino and it's on display
outside of las vegas but here's an
interesting story about that
the posse that ambushed bonnie and clyde
was made up of six people
texas ranger frank hamer former ranger
manny galt who was with the highway
patrol
dallas county deputies bob alcorn and
ted hinton and bienville parish sheriff
henderson jordan and his deputy prentice
oakley and they all hated each other
they all hated each other they all wrote
they gave conflicting versions of the
ambush afterward each trying to make
themselves look like the heroes and
everybody else non-heroes
the car
after the ambush was returned
reluctantly by henderson jordan who
wanted to sell it and keep the money to
the original owner had been stolen
from kansas
and the owner sold it bullet holes an
offer she ran then she sold it to a man
named charles stanley who billed himself
as the crime doctor
and started taking the car around county
fairs all over the country with a
lecture that crime doesn't pay he hired
clyde's mother and father emma's mother
and john dillinger's father to come
along
and he had a little slide show that was
mostly the pictures the mug shots of
clyde and of john dillinger
and when he would give his lecture he
would talk about how the methvin family
sold out bonnie and clyde
frank hamer always wanted to protect his
sources so he had insisted that the
hamers had i mean the methods had
nothing to do with it
and when stanley took his show into
austin texas where hamer lived during
the show frank hamer all six foot three
of them with old lucky i guess still to
decide leaped on stage
told stanley to get out of town slapped
his face with a huge hand so hard he
knocked him down
and destroyed his slides
stanley had a second set of slides and
he kept taking the car around but not in
texas because he was afraid of hamer
when he finally came back to show it off
in dallas at the state fair he hired two
bodyguards to protect him from frank
hamer those bodyguards were ted hinton
and bob alcorn
the dallas deputies who were in the
ambush that's how much those guys hated
each other
uh yes ma'am
cw never existed uh cw is actually a
composite of several members of the
barrow game and that's one of the
reasons that this this movie which again
is wonderful entertainment is not
historically accurate
so there was no cw cw was equal parts wd
jones and henry methvin but there there
was no cw
uh wait yes sir um i believe blanche
when she um got out of jail
she had
strike
she striked up a relationship with the
coffees
and when she got out of jail she went
and spent some time with them
um
at their home
before she went back the coffees were
were wonderful folks by
mrs uh coffee i was hoping she was here
and that we could introduce her to the
crowd ma'am would you stand up
to everybody right in the front row this
is this is the widow of
sheriff coffee
if you if you want to talk about real
heroes let's talk about
this lady and her husband now blanche
had been sentenced to prison for
shooting at him
they forgave her they were friends to
her they protected her
there are good people in this story and
the coffees are two of them ma'am it's
such an honor to see you here tonight
and we all treasure hold coffee's memory
it's getting towards the the witching
hour and tip off so maybe we'll do two
more questions and then of course i
would be happy to sign books for you and
let me assure you go down together is
the perfect gift for every occasion
uh
who would like to ask another question
yes ma'am
would you talk into the microphone so
everybody can hear you
well i should whisper this because i
want to know if the real clyde
yes
let me take the pressure off thank you
uh this is one of my favorite stories
in involved in this research now in the
movies
you may have noticed that there was a
hint that clyde was shall we say
a tad underdeveloped in the romance
department we will be tactful
and people have wondered if this was
true
there is a fabulous historian in texas
named john neal phillips
and john neal decided he was going to
get to the bottom of this clyde had
several girlfriends before bonnie and
one was a young woman named eleanor b
williams who clyde had a number of
escapades with john neal found her
and as he described it to me here there
is a lovely elderly lady
and he's come to see her because he
wants to ask the question
and he's trying to think how do i put
this in words
so she's telling stories about oh that
clyde you know he was so self-conscious
about his height that when he and i
would take our picture together he'd
want to stand on the curb so he'd look
taller and johnny is going well isn't
that fascinating
and finally he just couldn't do it
and she looked at him and she grinned
and said
you want to know don't you
john neal said yes ma'am
and he said she drew herself up and said
honey
he didn't have any trouble at all
so uh
i'm going to take her word for it
she was there one more question maybe
would somebody like to ask
way there in the back let's uh let's
give a little attention to the folks in
the back
if clyde was so good at stealing cars
why did he start robbing banks
for a couple of reasons he he had bigger
dreams than settling for what you could
get
from
reselling a stolen car in particular he
was hoping at some point to lead a raid
on eastern prison farm and free all the
prisoners just as a way of getting even
he needed more money for that than he
could get otherwise but he was a
pathetic bandit
most times they came away without any
money at all once they got chased away
drove into a herd of hogs and killed a
couple of the pigs and one time when
they actually did pull off a fairly
successful robbery in minnesota they
came away with sixteen hundred dollars
the only problem was instead of crisp
bills it was silver dollars and they had
to try to run down the street looking
like santa claus hauling his pack
he had a lot of ambition he did not have
the
thief skills to achieve them folks
i'm honored that you came it's been very
exciting for me this is a wonderful
facility the obviously kansas city
library is is special
and i hope they keep doing these
programs i'll be over here if you want
to get a book signed or ask any more
questions and go missouri
[Applause]
jeff guin is the author of several books
including the 16th minute life in the
aftermath of fame mr gwen was formerly a
book editor for the fort worth star
telegram
this event was hosted by the kansas city
public library for more information
visit kclibrary.org
joseph
book tv's live coverage of the tucson
festival of books continues with a panel
on how to write history for a popular
audience the panel includes outside
magazine editor-at-large hampton sides
former fort worth star telegram
editor-at-large jeff guinn
and literary agency founder james
donovan
this
well i want to welcome everyone to the
tucson festival
of books
it uh of course is even livelier and
better attended than last year i was
stunned by the success last year
and uh this year is absolutely wonderful
so we want to thank
the festival and all the people that
work so hard
to uh make it a success and to keep
the book alive in america which is
something everyone up here on this panel
is uh is dedicated to
um
my name is paul hutton i am a professor
at the university of new mexico which i
hope you won't hold against me
and uh i am the executive director of
the western writers of america and our
topic today is indeed the american west
and history as
bestseller
this particular session is sponsored by
the alliance bank of arizona we want to
thank them
and
the presentation will last approximately
an hour
and
we'll go about 40 minutes we'll open it
up for questions if you do have
questions you need to come up here to
the microphone and ask your question at
the microphone so uh i'll give you kind
of a high sign you could form a line if
you want to
and we need to do that because we want
to welcome c-span to our session they
are broadcasting this today and we of
course
are eternally grateful to c-span and all
they do to keep
the book alive and literacy alive and
especially american history live
in our country and so we welcome them
um
at the conclusion of our session uh
please join us and the authors at the
signing area which is uh ariel one
and it is tint b you may all want to
write that down and while you're writing
it down and you're reaching in for your
pins uh reach on over and turn those
cell phones off too if you would
i actually remembered to do mine
and
area one tint b is located south and
west of the student union and the
authors will be uh autographing their
books there
let me uh introduce to you our panel
all of whom have had great success
recently
with uh with history books
and books about the american west
um at the end of the table is jim
donovan the founder and president of jim
donovan literary a literary agency in
dallas texas he is a graduate of the
university of texas we take that kind of
hard in new mexico where i'm from but
that's all right
um
he's worn many hats in in his life in
the publishing business beginning his
career in publishing in the in an austin
bookstore back in 1981 moving to dallas
in 84 to become a buyer for a regional
bookstore chain he's been an editor and
now of course he's an agent and even
more importantly for our purposes of
course is a best-selling author with his
uh recent book a terrible glory
published by little brown
on custer and the little bighorn which
los angeles times said was the last word
on the last stand
somehow
donovan and i both know that's not true
um
it'll never be the last word on the last
standing now since he's absolutely
evidently infatuated with uh
uh people invading other people's
countries and getting wiped out
he's doing the alamo
um
[Laughter]
i always like it uh you know you go into
someone's backyard they shoot you and
then you're a hero it's very good um
jeff guinn um
has written um
15 books in his career he is also a
graduate of the university of texas for
six years he was the book editor at the
fort worth star telegram
and um
he just informed me that he his uh
publishers informed him that his book
the autobiography of santa claus
published in 2003 has now sold 500 000
copies which is pretty sweet so
congratulations on that
and naturally you know once you've
written about santa claus and had a huge
success you would want to write about
psychotic killers and so uh
jeff then turned to go down together the
true untold story of bonnie and clyde
published by simon schuster in 2009
and
he is currently working um deciding to
switch sides and go with the law after
seeing what happened to bonnie and clyde
he's now working on wyatt earp
and at the end of the table is hampton
sides who is uh did not go to uh the
university of texas uh but did barely
crawl through yale university
and uh i've actually seen the paper i
didn't believe it until he showed it to
me
he is from memphis where he was born and
raised uh he's had a very uh successful
career in journalism he is an editor at
large with outside magazine which i know
many of you uh uh read um his book ghost
soldiers in 2001 about
the bataan death march and a heroic
rescue attempt in the philippine
campaign
was made into a motion picture and of
course his blood and thunder the story
of kit carson in the american west
published by double day in 2006
has been an enormous success and has
sort of resurrected the name of kit
carson in american history
hampton is now
he resides in santa fe he followed
carson west and settled right work it
did for a while
and uh he has just completed
hell hound on his trail which is the
story of the king assassination and the
manhunt for the assassin which will be
published by double day next month
coming right out so we're all looking
forward to that
i think a good place to start
a discussion like this and we'll just
start
with
with jim
is why
did you select this uh
this topic i actually know why donovan
selected it he has the same tragic
addiction uh that i have to custer there
are no 12-step programs you're doomed
for life
but how in the world do you do you take
something that you love a story that you
love and that you've always been
fascinated with and turn it into a best
seller and in fact convince a publisher
that they need to publish a book on
something that everyone believes they
already know about are you finished i am
done you're on
we might get a word in edgewise here
i had done an earlier book a coffee
table book on the subject of the battle
with a little big horn and as you know
coffee table uh books are not by nature
very extensive or in-depth but doing
that book about 10 years ago i realized
that there had been so much written
so much research done on this battle
recently in the past 20 years especially
archaeological forensic results that
hadn't been integrated into one
narrative so
and of course once you get going on
custer you get hooked so that's the
answer to that
um
i persuaded my publisher that uh even
though there had been
oh how many paul four zillion books on
the subject uh five actually yeah that
uh one more
the market could bear one more and
uh
spent about four years three or four
years researching the book
and i'm totally hooked now on last
stands as you can see
it's been a last dance and people who
didn't quite make it out of the building
jeff
why in the world did you go from
santa claus so i believe everyone in
this room likes
to
to a controversial
pair like bonnie and clyde
although i didn't realize that for a
long time all of my books seem to be
about
the reality
of a person or people
and the myths that that grow up around
them
and i think it's important for us to
understand not just that a lot of the
history we believe is mostly mythology
but what it tells us about ourselves
that we created these myths that we
believe in them and love them in the
case of bonnie and clyde
i was wondering how could two of the
most inept criminals who ever lived and
they were inept
most of the time they had to break into
gum machines for their meal money
but you take these two kids from a
desperate dallas slum who are doomed the
minute a professional lawman really
decides to hunt them down
and how did we come to believe in them
as these glamorous figures that seem to
represent a romantic version of
depression america
that was the question that i wanted to
answer and that was the book i ended up
writing
in hampton
you and i of course know that
christopher kit carson is indeed
probably in terms of american history
the most significant of all of that
great quartet of frontier heroes uh
boone crockett
carson and cody but he is the one least
known in fact
i had about six months before your book
came out published a cover story in true
west magazine entitled why is this man
forgotten and of course he's not
forgotten anymore thanks to uh blood and
thunder and now hollywood is pounding on
your door
to perhaps make that into a movie which
will finally bring the carson story to
an international audience
why did you pick kit carson and how did
you sell that idea to uh to your
publisher
well i live in santa fe and anywhere you
go in new mexico you see kit carson's
name you know there's the carson
national forest and there's
carson up in taos where he's buried
there's carson park and carson uh
avenue and all over the west you know
carson city carson pass rivers streams
uh trails named after this guy he's sort
of a jack of the box jack in the box of
american history a sort of a zelig
figure or something and uh i i was just
i just asked stupid questions you know
who was this guy i i really didn't know
who he was i was he a villain was he a
hero i had been to canyon deshay and
arizona and heard that
one version of events which is that he
was a genocidal maniac and
tried to reconcile that with what little
i remember from reading uh juvenile
biographies i think you know he was
supposedly a great uh plucky intrepid
hero from uh
uh from these books that i had vaguely
remembered reading
so i was interested in you know how do
you reconcile genocidal maniac with a
great american folk hero and uh of
course found along the way that truth
was somewhere in the middle that that he
had this incredible varied um and um
and sort of getting to what you were
talking about with bonnie and clyde um
you know he was a legend he was a myth
in his own time because of all of these
blood and thunder books that were
published uh these books that
uh they were essentially the first dime
novels the first mass literature and he
was invariably portrayed as this action
figure hero you know 10 feet tall always
won the ladies uh was uh it was said he
would kill two indians before breakfast
and uh that's considered a good thing
back then and so there was this myth
even in his own lifetime uh herman
melville uh actually in one passage of
moby dick uh compares him favorably to
to uh hercules um so in his own lifetime
he had to live with this mythology um
and i i guess like like jeff i was
interested in sort of the
the contrast uh between the myth and and
the real person and that's what really
fueled and animated uh the book
we're finding in in the time in which we
live that um the story of the west and
western history is very much contested
ground in america and it's part of what
a lot of people call the cultural war
that's going on for sort of the heart
and soul of our national identity and
all of these characters are uh our
western characters like i consider
bonnie and clyde
along with pretty boy floyd and and
dillinger who was captured actually by
the arizona authorities not very far
from where we're sitting and sent back
to indiana i certainly consider bonnie
and clyde the last of the kind of
western outlaws it was still the time of
mobility and they and they were very
identified with the west but all of them
are steeped in the kind of controversy
we see
um in western history today and so uh of
course certainly custer who um is uh at
the center and has been for
really 50 years now this sort of
struggle for uh
ownership of the story of the american
west how did you deal with that jim how
did you deal with the controversy of of
custer
well
i was
what i wanted to do was tell this story
as samuel elliott morrison one of the
great
nonfiction history writers we've ever
had
he said a good writer of history should
observe three things accuracy
vigor and objectivity
i thought that if i tried to
write this story and research it
thoroughly
and let the story tell itself it would
kind of take care of itself
um
if i think if you start worrying about
what group
you know
which of these groups is going to be you
know bothered by what you write it can
just get in the way what i wanted to do
besides tell the story anew was
in my research for the earlier book i
had read a lot of the books that were
out there and
noticed that a lot of them had
kind of just assumed
mistakes
and and parts of the myth and the legend
that were just wrong
one person writes it somewhere somebody
else writes it incorporates it into a
story and after a while let's just
accept it as truth
um i wanted to kind of scrape off those
barnacles off this vessel uh
the battle of the little bighorn and of
course one of the things that's most
fascinating about this battle is it's a
mystery i think that's one of the
reasons that it's been written about
more than gettysburg is that
there's a mystery about what happened
specifically with custer's uh
battalion of five companies and how they
got massacred and there were indian
witnesses but for a hundred years nobody
took those seriously as paul knows they
were just kind of dismissed as being
irreconcilable but a lot of work has
been done in the last 20 years to sort
of examine those and realize that they
did have a lot of um
very reliable information to tell about
the battle and that's another the other
reason that i wanted to write this was
to see if i could find out what really
happened to custer's command uh
specifically and how they actually got
to where they they ended up and were
massacred on that hill and i i think i
did and i think there's enough material
from the indian accounts that have been
that weren't taken seriously for 100
years and also the the new forensic and
archaeological research they've done uh
over the past 20 25 years to do that
well and with custer of course you
confronted a character who once was
highly regarded and whose reputation has
fallen precipitously uh and now is
almost viewed as a as a sort of a punch
line in late night comedy
um bonnie and clyde are just the and you
treat him actually quite positively um
as uh not completely i hope no no not
completely but not as as a buffoon but
bonnie and clyde they're sort of just
the opposite i mean there's a whole aura
of romance that surrounds them of course
uh all of this driven by hollywood and
even the uh faye dunaway warren beatty
movie was not the first about them i
mean they've they've long fascinated
artists
your book kind of brings them down a bit
uh
how do you deal with that jeff i don't
know if it brings them down
one of the mistakes i think a lot of us
make when we're writing history
is we tend to try to apply modern
perceptions and modern beliefs
to a time that may have been entirely
different
and so in writing about bonnie and clyde
i tried to keep in mind
that i wanted readers to have context
you don't just write what people did if
you do that you've written a textbook
what you try to help readers understand
is how they did things and why they did
things
and to do that you have to try to
understand the time
and the place
and yes
the more modern day bonnie and clyde
barrow gang fans
believe they look like warren beatty and
faye dunaway
but the fact remains that bonnie and
clyde gained their initial
notoriety in america
they were really the first
electronic media icons
because with wire services those goofy
pictures they posed for could be in
newspapers
all over the country so what you really
have to do to understand their initial
appeal is they were the late 1920s early
1930s 30s
ancestors of brangelina
and and everybody was just speculating
on their love affair and the close
bonnie war and everything else
so once you understand the time when you
understand the attitudes of the time a
little better i think that always gives
us a clearer perspective of who people
really were
well in hampton
kit carson of course um
may have been forgotten before your book
around the country but certainly in new
mexico he's kind of a searing memory and
is not a positive figure at all and so
um you began a journey that led you to
uh
have to
reimagine carson and rewrite that
southwestern myth
well i think it's possible that carson
has eclipsed
custer as the most hated man in indian
america he's like the the kind of a
shorthand for um
uh
genocidal campaigns or um
uh
scorched earth campaigns the roundup of
the navajo people
but you know carson's just a very very
interesting guy who's full of surprises
this great indian
hater supposedly uh spoke something like
six or seven indian languages his first
wife was indian arapaho
they had two children she died in
childbirth her second uh his second wife
was cheyenne um
that marriage didn't last very long she
kicked she kicked him out of her teepee
what they call the cheyenne divorce but
um
nonetheless this was a man who
understood uh
american indian culture and lived much
of his young adulthood uh more like a
native american than a white guy but he
also spoke french and spanish and his
third and final wife was spanish he
converted to catholicism and lived in
taos and married into this spanish
family so this was kind of this
multicultural guy before that was ever a
term he just moved very easily and very
organically through all these different
worlds
the plains indians uh he was
particularly close to the ute indians
so you know this great indian hunter
becomes much more complicated uh and
then this uh
this person who is eclipsed custer
becomes a much more complicated much
more interesting guy i think when you
when you begin to see the totality of
his life and not just focus on the one
campaign the navajo campaign that has
really eclipsed his uh you know his
reputation has become uh so close so
intimately tied to that one campaign
really interesting guy and i also used
him almost as a he was a
a way to talk about the larger story of
manifest destiny and the conquest of the
west because this one guy this
illiterate back woodsman from missouri
who had run away at age 16 um
is is like this zelig character he keeps
cropping up and he keeps bumping into
history and intersecting with with uh
the destinies of of you know generals
and writers and uh
all the movers and shakers of the of the
westward uh push
he he's this uh he's this this sort of
little through line and it's kind of a
joy uh for a writer to come across a
character like that who can kind of pull
it all together and um and so he's not
he's not a biography of kid carson blood
and thunder is really a story about the
american west uh in which he is the
central
through line or the the person who sort
of connects the dots
all of these characters and i think it's
something we notice with a lot of uh
western characters seem to be
self-conscious carson perhaps the least
but one of the things that struck me in
jeff's book was that in the famous death
car uh riddled with bullets where bonnie
and clyde were finally shot down by that
posse there was a copy of walter noble
burns's biography brand new biography of
billy the kid in the back seat and
bonnie of course talked about um
jesse james at one time in some poetry
she wrote i'd like all three of you to
uh to talk about
that
that self-conscious nature
of these characters and you want to
start jeff uh
with bonnie and clyde uh nobody loved
their notoriety more than clyde barrow
and bonnie parker
they wanted to be famous
they knew that a lot of the stories
written about them had no basis in
reality and they were still pleased
they would the only thing they were good
at and this was clyde was stealing cars
and they would steal a car every few
days and they would abandon it the
police would find it and in the car they
would always find the latest newspapers
and true crime magazines with stories
about the barrow gang
they tried to encourage the right
perception of themselves
bonnie was appalled that people really
thought she smoked cigars
clyde actually sent a threatening letter
to the publisher of the fort worth star
telegram
saying that if you ever print another
story that says my underworld mate
smokes cigars
i know where you and your reporters live
and the star telegram until after the
bodies were certified as dead in
louisiana never printed another mention
of body with a cigar
but but again they were trying to
overcome who they really were they were
both crippled
in the last year of their lives clyde
had been crippled ever since he cut off
two of his own toes to get a prison duty
and bonnie actually could not walk
the last year of her life because her
leg was so terribly damaged in
a car wreck
they they lived mostly in filth camping
in their cars by rivers so they could
take baths
and
to them the exciting thing was that at
least they were
known for something they knew they were
going to die
they expected it and just wanted it to
be a spectacular run right up to that
which of course wasn't the case with uh
with kit carson or custer i don't think
jim
well of course i think we all know that
custer was
a kind of a glory hound loved
the attention ever since he was a young
captain in the civil war who was
bumped right up to brigadier general a
few days before
gettysburg
and adopted that was back when uh
you could dress a little differently and
he certainly did uh somebody described
him a fellow officer as a circus
performer gone mad because he had a
bright red
kravit and uh kind of a sailor's top
suit in a way but um he wasn't the only
one that was like that jeb stewart who
was his counterpart uh in the south
uh great calvary commander
also dressed quite
strikingly but i think he got a taste
for
the press then because of course they
they loved covering him because he was
so colorful and this was before they
published photographs that was until the
1890s in newspapers and magazines but
they used woodcuts in harper's and frank
leslie's is that right yes yeah and uh
of course people got a got a sense of of
who he was and
uh
newspapers and magazines loved them
because of that and fed off it and he
actually became a very good writer
his material is still
easy to read it's not too overburdened
with those victorianisms
that makes some of that stuff most of
that stuff unbearable now anything
before about 1880 or 1890. um on this
last campaign the little bighorn
campaign he actually
filed stories for a new york newspaper i
think it was the herald tribune
anonymously
so he was very aware of what the press
could do
well carson i think was in a lot of ways
kind of the anti-custer i mean he was
very uncomfortable with his celebrity
for most of his life he didn't
understand it he didn't understand where
it was coming from that people back east
needed this hero to personify
manifest destiny he certainly didn't
know what manifested destiny was in a
sense he he didn't use that word it was
too high falutin a term for him he uh
was also illiterate so
he couldn't read these horrible books i
dare you to read these blood and
thunders they're terrible i went to the
library of congress and read some of
them and you know they're absolutely
horrible pulp fiction books some of the
you know very precursors to the to the
modern western but um he didn't get him
he didn't understand why these
why these
writers were writing these stories he
didn't get any money from them he didn't
get any um any consent to use his name
they painted a caricature of him that he
essentially spent his whole life trying
to live down and then there was there
was a clipper ship named the kid carson
there was a steamboat named the kit
carson there were broadway plays there
was the mention in moby dick uh yeah you
know the thing just blew up and uh it's
at a certain point his career he he
realized he needed to kind of seize
control of of all this press and he
tried to hire a writer to to to tell his
story and washington irving came very
close to saying yes to to doing uh sort
of a definitive book about kid carson if
he had i probably would have never
written blood and thunder um
instead they got a series of hacks that
kind of worked on his story and he also
wrote
a dictated i should say because he
couldn't write uh an autobiography which
is very very uh bare bones and um but
but you know this is kind of like the
opposite of custer or maybe the opposite
of buffalo bill there's someone who was
never successful in turning his fame
into something bigger he would he died
essentially a pauper he could never
seem to capitalize nor did he have the
inclination to capitalize on on his fame
but it was certainly something that he
spent his whole career grappling with
and trying to figure out why does this
country back east that i ran away from
seem to need a superhero um to uh to
personify this movement
it's of course good that uh custer wrote
his autobiography when he was 34 since
he's dead at 36. it's good to get the
record in before you check out not as
early as william barrett travis right
who wrote it about
24-23 that's well his was a diary though
but uh yeah um getting a plug for your
next book we'll get to that soon
actually there is a mention by someone
else
who clerked for him that he had written
an autobiography a short autobiography
at the age of about twenty-four but it's
been lost well it's always good to uh to
get was done quick
now i'm i'm in a business i'm in the
academy uh and oftentimes i'm kind of
struck by the fact that that many of my
colleagues in fact a large number seem
to believe that if you actually would
sell a book
in a bookstore for like real humans that
want to read
that you have sold out you have betrayed
your calling uh and in fact the kind of
commercial success that these three
gentlemen have had as writers uh would
pretty well do in the career of any
academic historian
and the gentleman in particular wanted
to talk about that uh this seems to be
something that festers in them i don't
understand it at all
but there is an academic approach to
history and it's very different from the
kind of popular approach and the history
books and biographies sell very well in
america and yet uh the academy and
especially this is troubling in western
history seems to be pulling back from
trying to write for a greater audience
and you gentlemen all self-consciously
write for for
the greater audience and um
how do you how do you see yourselves and
we'll start with you hampton um since
you went to yale as uh
as different from your academic
colleague
historians
well um i i did go to yale and at the
time um it really had one of the
heavyweight history departments it
probably still does um
it was really really uh packed with
talent but the four years i was there i
do not recall ever hearing the word
pleasure
ever being uttered
history was not supposed to be
pleasurable
we historians are
very deadly serious people
we put on robes and
we commune with dead people we're we're
druids essentially and um
uh
you know we go into the stacks and and
there's we have secret methodologies
that no one else is supposed to know
about um and that's sort of the way it
was taught and also the writing of
history um and the appreciation of of
history as i was as it was taught to me
in in college was
essentially argumentation uh you you
have an argument you have a thesis and
you you state your thesis and then you
marshal your evidence and you argue your
points and then you build towards a
summation um
and you have your closing argument and
then then you have to go before your
professor and defend your thesis in
person um
this is very legalistic
i think a bunch of lawyers early on
hijacked the history departments of of
most universities and um the idea of
telling stories the idea of actually
having stories that have plot and
character and suspense and dialogue and
all these attributes of storytelling
that we know from fiction and from
movies and television and all the other
modes of communication
never really have entered very well into
the history departments
although i know two things one is that
there are a lot of
academic historians who do secretly go
home at night
without telling anyone and they read uh
shelby foote or david mccullough or
nathaniel philbrick or or barbara
tuchman and they don't like to admit it
but i think even paul does this
and um so so the hostility that exists
between uh professional academic
historians and professional popular
historians i think really is is kind of
contrived it shouldn't it shouldn't
exist i think there's there's a place
for narrative history in universities
perhaps as a multi-disciplinary approach
you could get a major in narrative
history that would be you know
english department
like a mixed major or something like
that
uh i think there's a place for it and i
think that the hostility that exists is
um unfortunate and you know there's a
place for all kinds of history and i
think also the history as we know it is
going to die as a discipline unless we
do sort of inject some life into it
by having a greater um uh primacy of
narrative history within the cat the
overall academy of uh of of history but
that's just kind of my own little my own
private theory i don't know if you guys
kind of see it that way or no i think
there's there's two things all of us who
write history have to keep in mind
the first thing is we're not writing
books to prove how smart we are
we are trying to write books that we can
share some information that we have in a
positive way that will interest not just
other avid historians but general
readers
in a lot of cases i think what happens
to folks who are academics
is they are
extending
their doctoral thesis or whatever and
they're writing something that they
believe they will be able to defend to
their colleagues
on the faculty
and not writing a book
on a fascinating subject for folks who
know something would like to know more
and expand their own knowledge
if you write if you're writing to
impress your friends and yourself
then just keep a blog online
or a diary that you xerox and send
around
otherwise try to remember the folks that
you're writing for who are interested in
the subject who want to know more
who have day jobs and maybe only have 30
minutes to read at night or gonna try to
grab an hour or two with your book on
the plane on a business trip or on a
vacation
if if you're not trying to reach out to
as many readers as you can
if you're not trying to share
information
spread the word get people thinking and
i bet everybody in this room reads
because you like to think
and you like to learn
if you're gonna if you're just going to
try to impress the people that you
already know
and make yourself look good to them
it it seems to me it's an invalid
exercise writing history is storytelling
and you want to tell the story to the
widest number of people
and share it in a positive and formative
way
one question paul did you wear that
tweed jacket just to provoke us
i did
and i in fact haven't put a tie on in
years uh being a southwesterner but i
did this and uh okay outside look like a
professor yeah you you three actually
make me want to defend the academy as
was a very uncomfortable position for me
well jeff uh touched on a few things i'm
also an agent and i deal with this a lot
and
one of the things
that
good writers of popular narrative
non-fiction uh in history because that
we're talking about that we have to
does is to pay more attention to
uh the things that make it more
interesting and readable and
the two main ones i think are story and
character those two elements and how
they're handled
for instance
i know some of us
the best writers use somewhat novelistic
techniques and i don't mean making
things up as in fiction i mean paying
more attention to how a story is told
how it's structured
and particularly character because i
don't know about you but i think i speak
for a lot of people that read
if i don't care about
who i'm reading about
then i'm not going to read very long
and
and if you don't concentrate on
character and make us at least care or
understand
about these people and their motivations
and reasons
then it's a history textbook and i don't
know many people who read history
textbooks for fun
for instance we're talking about
character
what i try to do in my books is humanize
the story and
when i research i have a file i had a
file for every one of custer's 31
subordinate officers and after three or
four there's just you just don't get
much information
when i'd find a nugget about what a
person was like it went in the file and
somehow i blended it into the narrative
and it gives you a little more
information about the character it makes
you i hope care about the character a
little more
well and might add to that also is a
style i mean you know when i was in in
college or when it whenever i've i've
been in an academic setting i've felt a
hostility to the idea of style that a
historian should have any style
of writing or a voice or a sense of kind
of unique
way of
getting their ideas across or telling
the story
and what i found that you have to do
if you come out of an academic setting
is you have to have uh this is a
scientific term you have to have a um
what's known as a corn cob ectomy um
you have to remove it you remove the
corn cob because it's really it does
affect you know i i assumed i i've gone
back and looked at my college papers and
uh you assume a voice that and this
isn't just history this is all academic
disciplines i think you assume a voice
it's not yours it's somebody else's it's
it's some approximation of an area diet
person that that you envision in your
mind and uh you have to remove that and
just start telling stories in a much
more organic and much more um
natural way big words
well i think probably the the easiest
way to say it is you don't want to write
a book that's a lecture
you want to write a book that's a
conversation with a reader
i i had to stand up because my corn cob
was hurting me as i said on the venture
did you how about the other one
the uh
i did want to talk a little bit more
about style
and all of your books which i ought to
uh i had to hold up for the audience
donovan's a terrible glory
go down together about bonnie and clyde
and of course hampton's
blood and thunder all available at your
local bookstore or off the internet or
right when we sign after the session is
over
but all are written very clearly very
forcefully
dare i even say in some cases gracefully
and lyrically
uh
all of us are going to keep going yeah
all of us
and many of us many of the viewers and
folks in this room we want to write we
struggle with writing and writing is
very very hard work uh
tell us this does not just come
naturally to you that you actually do
have to work at this
i was up it about a week ago i was up i
woke up at four in the morning
nothing to do with a corn cob but
i picked up a copy of david mccullough's
1776
which is a wonderful book and in some
ways
it has some similar structure character
themes as what i'm working on on the
alamo a revolution a ragtag army some
leaders
and i i picked up his book then
and i spent about an hour just looking
through
the first hundred pages to see how he
handled
attributable quotes i spent an hour just
doing that to see how he did it because
he's one of uh you know he's one of the
models he's the the gold standard here
although mr sides is rapidly approaching
that point
i'll pay you later
jim jim you're you're my agent could you
[Laughter]
for this i give him 15 percent
uh what if if you've got a secure ego
hampton doesn't
yep i went to the university of texas so
that means i got my credentials right
out there um
and this was in the 60s and i vaguely
remember it
i don't think any of us who write and
have kept writing and having some
success
don't have the same head-battering
moments everybody has who's trying to
write there are days when the magic
works and there are lots of days when
the magic doesn't
my own technique is
when i can't think of how i should be
saying something
i imagine that i'm having dinner with my
wife nora
if i were telling this story to nora
instead of writing it what are the
things i would want to tell her
so that she would understand it and then
i go back and try to work those things
in it's it is god-awful hard work but i
i do think i speak for everybody and
there are some other wonderful writers
in this room i i should point out some
folks who have done valuable valuable
work
that what could be more fun what could
be a bigger thrill
than trying hard to learn about things
and writing them and sort of carrying
them on a little bit and sharing them
with other people the joy does overcome
the pain but sometimes it hurts one hell
of a lot
it's not also you know it's not very
sexy work you know my son has watched me
work a seven-year-old son came to the
office one day and uh
watched me uh holding up a document
then i set the document down and then i
type a little bit i pick up that same
document look at it again
set it down
pick up another document
put it over on top of the this goes on
for hours my son's watching this
you know
thinking my my father's supposed to be
you know a successful writer this is
maybe something i would want to do one
day or something
and but then he looked at me and they
just said dad is it always like this
and
i think my kids think watching uh
watching me that is the most deadly dull
profession in the world and they would
never in a million years want to do it
because it is really hard work i mean it
is
you know you you just scratch your head
you're thinking about structure you're
thinking about plot you're thinking
about when did i last introduce this
character you know you're
you know the writing process not just
the research but the writing is agony at
times uh but it in the end is i think uh
a dream job even though my kids don't
believe me someday
they'll be good
of course the suicide rate with riders
is pretty high
and there's nothing to really work on
yourself self-esteem so much as looking
at a blank page for two or three days
and coming to realize what a total and
complete failure you are
which has never happened to any of these
gentlemen and and not only have they
published these bestsellers now they're
off on new projects and we ought to uh
we ought to talk about that uh hampton
your book is coming out uh in just a few
weeks would you tell us about well um
yeah it's it's a book about um well i
grew up in memphis and i think all
writers uh at some point want to go back
to the place where they came from and
uh i wanted in this case to go back to
the pivotal moment in the place where i
came from
april of 1968 in memphis and the
confluence of forces that brought king
to memphis my father was a lawyer and he
worked for the law firm that represented
uh king when he came on behalf of the
garbage workers who went on strike in in
the
fall of um excuse me spring of 1968. um
but i got kind of captivated by james
earl ray and
this story really became not so much the
story of the assassination is how the
fbi
tracked down james earl ray the largest
manhunt in american history at that time
um
two two million dollars
six thousand agents uh four different
countries he was finally caught by
scotland yard in in london two months
after the assassination as he was on en
route to becoming a mercenary soldier in
uh in rhodesia um it's a very
interesting story and uh you know i
guess in some ways like bonnie and clyde
you know the
rey has his own mythology and rey has
his own uh um
self-conscious um qualities of you know
trying to be kind of a folk hero i guess
um a very um very dark character uh
someone who i guess in a way in a way um
is a kind of a consummate um
villain in this story the villain
becomes in a sense the protagonist
though because it's really about how he
gets out of these different situations
how he assumes different identities and
almost gets away with this crime um
so and you want to talk about uh you're
working on and the title is oh the hell
uh it's called hellhound on his trail
and it's coming out um
at the end of april so uh i'll be going
on a book tour and talking about that a
lot in in the months to come and jeff
we're in your new stomping grounds we're
just north of tombstone arizona and your
next project is wyatt earp
one of the things
that surprised me about clyde barrow is
that clyde saw himself as sort of the
heir of the great western gunslinger i
mean clyde's heroes in life were jesse
james and billy the kid
i wanted to know more
about the era that spawned that sort of
mythology
about the the two gun toting lawmen and
the bad guys and everything else
and
i'm having a fascinating time working on
a book that's tentatively titled the
last gun fight which my new york editors
thought would be about this heroic
showdown in the streets of tombstone but
which they're learning as i send in my
draft chapters is actually about the
fascinating fabulous history of
southeast arizona
and the whole westward expansion of
america again not writing so much about
what people did
as how they did things and why they did
things
and i do want to say to the host city of
tucson that you have some of the best
historians i've ever run into here
folks who are dedicated to trying to
find out information and who who share
it very generously
this is this is a fun project and when
you're trying to decide what to buy
every relative and friend you ever had
for christmas next year
do keep it in mind
for this year copies of go down together
are still in the bookstore and jim
you're moving right on to uh right alamo
which is uh pretty uh pretty fabulous
material for a texan as you know and i
think somebody needs to interject here
and say if you don't know that paul
hutton is also a wonderful writer
uh
himself uh the book i wanted to write
after this was
on i wanted to write a book on the
titanic so as you can see i'm kind of
the literary equivalent of
the guy in the car ahead of you hate who
slows down with a horrible accident
there's something about them
i guess i'm fascinated by but and i
spent several months writing a proposal
and
my publisher liked it but they thought
well you know there's going to be a lot
of
titanic books coming out in 2012 the
100th anniversary so do you have
anything else i mean you you know you
did a great western book is there
anything another subject i mean
you know and i said well you know this
thing happened down here i live in
dallas
you know told him a little about it and
i said yeah i don't know maybe people
all over the country aren't as
fascinated by it as texans because it's
religion down in texas
the holy trinity is is crockett bowie
and travis
but
all of a sudden uh my agent who relayed
this to him said uh he jumped out of the
his seat and he was dancing uh in his
office when i told him about bowie
crockett and and travis the alamo and um
so now i'm doing a book on the alamo i
am not doing any more last stands i'm
not doing thermopylae masada anything
else i want to do a subject preferably
where there's some people alive still
that i can talk to about it
because that it drives you crazy as a
historian writing where everybody's been
dead for a while because you just think
why didn't somebody just ask this one
question that would have cleared up
everything yeah
not just dead but good and dead you know
right
as hampton how did you phrase this we
work in the the sepia
what was that phrase i don't know the
pain cave with the pain
don't tell me about the pain cave i'm in
it and you just got out of it and jeff's
in it but we we deal in the sepia
edge of the spectrum
those kind of subjects that are back
there and you see the the photos in
sepia tone
some people have in fact suggested that
uh historians
are so anti-social of course they spend
all their time locked in rooms uh
writing they can't deal with any humans
who are actually alive
and appreciate more the the dead who
don't usually talk back um if you have
any questions please come up to the
microphone right here and uh and ask
them of our panels we have about uh
about 10 15 minutes left yes sir
first of all thank you all for coming i
think uh just to speak on behalf of some
of us that have been involved with the
festival it's just terrific to have you
here so thank you
um
could you speak a moment about your
how do you come up with ideas how many
ideas are ahead of you uh as you're
thinking about what you want to write
about and also do you think about
tv and movies as you're writing would
you hope to see your ideas come out on
different screens
i i think about
i think about movies and cinema kind of
in the opposite way i think that i'm a
product of of modern culture and uh i've
seen a lot of movies and i think i think
and and influenced by film and so i
think in terms of scenes i think in
terms of character-driven plot um and so
my stories tend to be very i've been
i've been told very cinematic it's not
that i'm writing for the movies and
hopes that it will become a movie it's
that i'm actually influenced by that
form and that mode of storytelling and i
think probably all modern narrative
writers to a certain extent are we can't
help it if you go to see thousands of
movies over a lifetime you're going to
be
influenced by that um
so no i don't but as far as you know
thinking about i mean we all
hope that um
that a movie can can come out of a story
it's it's uh it's nice you're not
supposed to get too emotionally involved
though you're supposed to just you know
i think it was hemingway said you're
supposed to drive to the nevada
california border
in the dead of night and you go to your
trunk and you hurl your manuscript over
and then they go to their trunk and they
hurl the money over and then you part
ways you're not supposed to be
emotionally invested in it's just
nothing but heartbreak basically yeah
right now i don't think any of us
well we don't give much thought to you
know whether our books will be turned
into movies and they'll give us lots of
money no not at all but i uh
i have a degree in film
from texas uh
not yale
but
and that's a good point all i want to do
is reiterate what what hampton just said
because i i like to think uh seeing
those thousands and thousands of movies
and writing about them and and examining
them in detail
maybe contributed to
my
quote-unquote expertise uh in
storytelling
in a good way the the one other thing is
that when you undertake a book project
like we do you're going to devote two or
three years of your life to it so you
better not just come up with an idea i'm
going to do this book because i think i
can sell it to the movies because if you
hate what you're writing about or you
find it boring it would be two or three
laws of years
so the the thing we have to start with
is something we're interested in and we
care about in the story we want to tell
yes sir
good morning thank you for coming
appreciate it
what event
or person inspired you to become writers
and like for each one on the panel plus
mr hutton to answer that question thank
you mr hutton you should answer it first
i'm sure you've got a good story
well i will tell you it was uh walt
disney's uh television show davy
crockett starring fence parker and uh it
i i didn't see the the show i was
actually in england at the time but i
got the comic book and i read that comic
book and um it truly it sounds corny but
it inspired my whole love of history and
i went from there to custer
and just kept going
following the donovan road and
i decided i'd become a historian because
i just loved history so much and uh it's
been a great choice it's been a great
ride a great profession
well for me it was tarzan
well that was the first when i was sick
one uh day when i was nine years old my
mother bought me tarzan and
boom over the next two or three years i
read every edgar ice burrows book that
existed and read nothing but fantasy and
science fiction for the next several
years until i was about 16.
now i'm allergic to elves dragons
wizards
all that kind of thing
but
that got me hooked and
i don't know how it led here but
i found i was a decent writer in high
school did the usual newspaper thing
didn't follow it into college as these
two gentlemen probably did but
worked in bookstores obviously and and
somehow got here
i had the meanest fourth grade teacher
who ever lived miss arendes who pointed
out my faults regularly and she had a
right to
one day she made us write a paper a 250
word paper in the fourth grade
and we all complained about it and when
i got the paper back it was the only a
i'd ever gotten from her and she'd
written in red ink you should be a
writer and because miss arendes and god
were on personal terms and were never
wrong
i was nine years old and decided that's
what i had to do or else should find me
we're still in touch and i i in my
acknowledgements of every book i write i
always thank her
i i would say the first
the formative experience for me was the
first writer that i ever met was this uh
bearded sage that you may remember from
the uh ken burns civil war documentary
uh the great civil war historian shelby
foote uh he
and his son um
well his son and i were friends his son
was named huggy
uh the name the names in the south were
rather strange and um
we were in a rock band together and we
were uh in a room that may or may not
have been full of smoke
basically cranking up the hendrix doing
everything we could do to prevent shelby
from finishing his uh 6 000 page trilogy
of the civil war and he'd come up and
rap on the door and say you know hug it
turn that racket down i'm working on
appomattox and uh yeah
and we're like yeah right yeah yeah
so but later on i got to know shelby and
he really gave me some very very great
ideas about what narrative history can
aspire to to be
discussing past felonies on national
television is usually not a good idea
hampton
i said may or may not have been full of
smoke right yes sir
there's a custard book out there
entitled glory hunter could you paul and
jim comment on glory hunter
jim
well that was written by frederick van
der water who had been a novelist it's a
very stylishly written book very well
written it's easy to read that was the
era in the 30s a lot of what's the
phrase paul
the debunkers
that's it there were a lot of a lot of
debunking going on
and
custer's wife libby who outlived him by
50-something years she died in 1933
believe it or not lived at 71 park
avenue she was six days short of her
91st birthday
she died in 33 he had started the book a
couple years earlier
that came out in 34.
it's a good book well researched
but i think it's pretty clear
it doesn't take long to show that he was
slanted against custer and at every
instance tried to show how he was just
lucky at gettysburg and lucky here
so
that's glory hunter it's a wonderful
literary biography and it certainly was
the key uh book in changing custer's
image uh in the united states from this
very heroic uh martyr to our westward
expansion into kind of a villainous uh
indian fighter who uh
brought death to his men in his own
search for glory yes sir oh thank you uh
i have a comment for hampton and a
question for james uh
but first of all i'd like to say that uh
they they say that uh reading and
writing history is like going to a
foreign country and i want to thank you
all for stepping our passports here
today
for doing that uh the comment for
hampton is uh
oh probably several years ago my wife
and i were taking a tour of taos on a
beautiful fall day where all the trees
were yellow
and the tour guide took us by this
little gift shop on the way out to the
pueblo
and we saw this little man behind the
gift shop chopping wood
and he was doing it very skillfully and
very forcefully i just couldn't believe
for his small size how well he was
chopping wood
and a tour driver said that fellow is a
survivor of the baton death march
and i know there's a connection between
your two books because the arizona
national guard i guess i mean excuse me
new mexico national guard had gone over
to the philippines
i believe for ghost soldiers you know
and the
and the uh
anyway between new mexico and
philippines there's a connection
definitely yeah yeah and well the
question i had uh about custer was uh i
belong to a
study club up in denver and uh
uh of course people occasionally go up
to the battle site there and uh came
back and they were whispering there's a
rumor that custer
had two soldiers available
after he won the battle of little
bighorn to take off to the nearest
telegraph station to report his results
to the national republican
committee who was they were starting the
convention i believe
uh is that true or not well a man named
craig repass wrote a short little book
called custer for president
which he
takes on that question and i think he
does a pretty good job of
showing that there's really
barely a shred of evidence there was
never a mention in any newspaper about
custer never mentioned at the
convention it didn't work like that
anyway
and
there's a letter from
libby custer who he shared
almost everything with
uh written
about a week or two before the battle he
never got it but she spends a paragraph
or two discussing
the candidates for president and never
mentions uh you know the candidacy of
custer
yes sir thank you i have a question for
jeff gwyn about his forthcoming book on
wyatt and tombstone jeff i'm wondering
in your research and in your writing so
far
what has surprised you most about the
story as you've uncovered it
the things that are amazing me the most
are some of the history of southeast
arizona
and the ab the absolute combination uh
sort of an
it's almost a drug inducing atmosphere
and so enticing of tombstone elegance
and decadence at the same time
that i think so many folks out there
have have
a misunderstanding of what the town was
like what arizona territory was like
there's so much more to this story than
i ever would have guessed and there's so
many people who have very strong
opinions about all of it and at least
half of them no matter what i write will
decide i'm an idiot and probably evil
besides
uh
but that's what makes it fun there's so
much more to learn in this story than i
had originally thought
and yes sir one final question uh yes
this is for jeff also um
ever since the 1920s people been writing
books about tombstone and i know you had
to approach a lot of authors and
researchers
some of whom
don't quite agree with the other ones
and uh how did you manage that how do
you get to be able to talk to all those
people um my rule is always that i'll
talk to anyone who might have useful
information
i've had a couple of people say well if
you talk to so and so then i won't talk
to you
and my response is always well then i'm
sorry you and i aren't going to get a
chance to talk
there are many strong opinions in this
field and hampton runs into this all the
time jim runs into this all the time but
i think mostly we find our experiences
that once you start talking to someone
who has a genuine deep interest in a
subject and has done a lot of research
they want to talk about it
and if you're polite and you're
persistent people will talk to you as i
said it's always after your book is
published that half of them decide
you're an idiot
well ladies and gentlemen thank you so
much for coming again the books are
[Applause]
by james donovan blood and thunder by
hampton sides
and of course
go down together by jeff guin and they
will be
signing books in area one tint b thank
you all uh for being here and
thank you everybody thank you everybody
thank you
mr just knowing your point of view yeah
just
book tv's live coverage of the tucson
festival of books continues shortly with
retired general anthony zinni discussing
his book leading the charge
[Music]
hosted by our comcast cable partner
c-span's local content vehicle recently
visited many historic sites in
shreveport louisiana's third largest
city
learn more about shreveport all weekend
long on american history tv
the inevitable end
retribution
here is clyde barrel and bonnie parker
who died as they lived
by the gun
the officers were on the left side of
the road nearest the driver this
explains the fact that bonnie's body had
more bullet holes than clients
any one of these bullets would have been
fatal to both
but after having killed 14 people
most of whom were officers of the law
and having come safely through so many
gun battles it did not seem advisable to
fire just one bullet
bonnie and clyde were probably some of
the most notorious gangsters of the
1930s crime era in the united states
because their crime story began in texas
east texas and involved
louisiana they're very sort of connected
to the 1930s story of shreveport
as well probably most people associate
bonnie and clyde with uh with a very
intense two-year period
from 1932 to 1934 when they were
involved in a in a string of of armed
robberies and and murders throughout
this part of the united states we think
that bonnie and clyde actually met
initially in 1930 when bonnie parker was
working as a waitress in dallas texas
and soon after that clyde barrow went to
state prison
and so we know that they resumed their
relationship in 1932 in texas and their
first crime actually took place in
hillsborough texas not too far from
shreveport the shreveport times was
regularly reporting their exploits you
know in the newspaper and people in this
area kept up with it just like they did
the big uh gangsters of that era of
american history there was also of
course this was the age of john
dillinger it was the age of pretty boy
floyd as a matter of fact a lot of
people don't realize that all three of
those uh bonnie bonnie and clyde john
dillinger pretty boy floyd all were were
killed by law enforcement in the same
year in 1934 so people were really
engaged in that in that story probably
simultaneously horrified but fascinated
by these these criminals
in the great depression in early 1934
they were
implicated in a prison escape involving
a former associate of clyde burrows in
texas a man named raymond hamilton
they helped him escape from prison and
in the process of that shot and killed a
prison guard
and so that's when the really that the
net of law enforcement began to to close
around them was was after the the murder
of the prison guard early in 1934. so it
was april of 1934
that clyde barrow we know was in and
around shreveport
as a matter of fact there was a car that
was stolen in shreveport uh from
clydeberry solar car here in shreveport
and uh
actually abandoned it in kansas
and uh his fingerprints proved that of
course he had been in that air in this
area
even before he was spotted here we knew
that they were in and about the vicinity
just a few days before the ambush took
place in gibson louisiana
the
there was a a
local cafe here not too far from where
we're standing
uh called the majestic cafe
and on this street somewhere between the
point we're standing and a couple of
blocks from here
clyde
barrow was spotted somewhere near the
majestic cafe and someone in the
neighborhood phoned the local
authorities and it was because of that
report
that
law enforcement
from the region including of course uh
texas rangers
knew that uh they were in the vicinity
and so that's when the the net sort of
began to close around bonnie and clyde
and and their ambush occurred actually
just four days after clyde barrow was
spotted here on this street
they were ambushed not far from gibson
louisiana on a rural road
there was actually
the ambush laid in place by by local law
enforcement uh over in in that part of
louisiana who knew had on good
intelligence where they were going to be
what their movements were
and uh they laid in wait for them on a
stretch of road
and
and of course as many people know
opened fire on the car that they were
riding in
and bonnie and clyde both suffered
over 50 separate bullet wounds each in
that ambush the story of bonnie and
clyde like the story of john dillinger
and others like
that from this era really is a part of i
think a broader social commentary about
america and the great depression
if you look at crime rates in the united
states there's a definite spike that
takes place in particular in armed
robberies in the early 1930s and a lot
of social scientists have been quick to
to ascribe that to
depressed economic conditions the fact
that you have
banking failures
business failures farm closures
and
to the point that you could almost blame
the great depression for this era of the
american gangster
when in fact that's probably the reason
that people
followed their stories and maybe even
associated uh
some some
nostalgia with them perhaps in the same
way we would the outlaws of the old west
but it really is a very brief period in
american history where you see this the
early 1930s
all weekend along american history tv is
featuring shreveport louisiana
learn more about shreveport and find out
where cspan's local content vehicles are
going next online at cspan.org
local content
you're watching american history tv all
weekend every weekend on c-span 3.
showcasing the city's history
learn more about waco all weekend here
on american history tv
the institute of texan cultures down in
san antonio said that the second most
well-known thing in texas is the texas
rangers the first being the alamo i mean
everyone remembers the alamo right
but they've had a long legacy and we're
talking about 200 years of that history
and heritage of upholding values of
law and order and justice
and it's something that a lot of
foreigners have taken to i mean we hear
about ranger reenactment groups in the
ukraine in belgium
france and you name it and their
popularity is widespread and it all
began with this
innocent uh beginnings of just
protecting
their friends and their family members
from indian
raids and so it's grown it's adapted and
developed into the
law enforcement agency that we now
compare to the fbi of texas
in 1823 the tech strangers were
established stephen f austin who's kind
of the father of texas
was given a
was given permission from the republic
of mexico to bring the first 300
settlers to texas and start colonizing
the area
when they got here stephen fosten
quickly realized there was a need to
protect those settlers from indian raids
specifically the comanche indian most
people have heard of them
and
he asked for a group of 10 volunteers to
range the countryside so you were a
volunteer if you owned it you had it if
you didn't own it you didn't have it and
they
basically banded together when they need
to protect from those indian raids and
that's how they got their start
over the years they've evolved into the
modern law enforcement agency that we
know today well their evolution took
place over the course of about 200 years
they're celebrating their 200th
anniversary in 2023
but that evolution was slow and it kind
of took place over time of course
eventually the most native americans
were relocated and so the need
and that threat was no longer there
texas developed
during the civil war and after and
became more modern
state and as this development came about
so the rangers would change
of course in the early 1900s you have
the discovery of oil and texas is the
place where you can get rich fast if you
can get some of that oil and so a lot of
people started coming to texas
and the rangers would start working
security in the oil fields because there
was a lot of chaos and turmoil during
that time
there were things that occurred in the
early 1900s like prohibition of course
the united states government decided
alcohol should be illegal unfortunately
texas borders mexico and mexico has a
lot of tequila
so the
rangers started acting as a border
security
which is something they do today of
course it's not alcohol it's narcotics
and other things that they're working to
protect texans from
so
their evolution really took place as the
times and the error
that they were living in changed and
they always adapted in 1935 they were
formalized under the department of
public safety dps when that was created
they created their first crime lab that
year
and so they vote you know were working
forensics
back then
just like they are today and so they've
kind of evolved with the the changes as
the criminals adapt the rangers adapt
the museum has a marvelous collection of
material that goes all the way back to
the founding of the rangers in 1823 we
try to collect not only the earliest
material but also the things that the
rangers are currently using in their
service today so it's a collection that
has somewhere in the neighborhood of
probably ten to fifteen thousand
individual pieces
and uh dates almost over a two hundred
year time span
well the museum is really a complex and
the museum is one of the big portions of
the another is the texas ranger hall of
fame it was set up in 1976 for the 175th
anniversary of the rangers and honors at
this point 30 rangers who made major
contributions to the service or gave
their lives under heroic circumstances
we have paintings or portraits of all of
those rangers they really begin with
stephen f austin
austin was very successful with his
rangers they fought not only
managed to make the area reasonably safe
for settlement from indian raids but
when the
texas war for independence
broke out the rangers played a major
role in texas gaining its independence
by staving off the mexican army long
enough to
allow the colonists to build their own
army and develop a strategy
and as a result texas became its own
independent nation the republic of texas
for about 10 years
but austin is regarded as being
founder of the texas rangers in 1823 and
so he made it into the texas ranger hall
of fame we have some interesting
collections that are tied not only to
specific rangers but also to what the
rangers do one of the most interesting
ones to visitors is our collection of
u.s paper currency
it actually predates the u.s it goes all
the way back to the republic of texas in
the 1830s and 40s when texas was its own
nation and issued its own currency and
although there wasn't a lot backing it
it was it's really interesting to
collectors to know that the state of
texas at one point was printing its own
money
one of the other things we have is a
collection of engraved firearms firearms
engraving really is an art form and it's
one that is kind of fading out today but
back in the time period between say the
1850s and about the 1950s
it was a uh goal of anyone that carried
firearms on a on a regular basis to
probably have one one pistol or one
rifle that was very very well decorated
there were
persons who did this to an unbelievable
level a lot of them had failing eyesight
later in life because from staring and
engraving microscope almost
microscopically for hours and hours and
hours
but we have a collection of that some
rangers today still get still have their
sidearms their pistols engraved or at
least some of them engraved so they can
have them the slang term for that is
barbecue guns because rangers today
still wind up doing luncheon speeches to
kiwanis clubs and rotary clubs and
things like that and they'll very often
carry a firearm with them that's been
very well you know very finely decorated
and everything else but as the cost of
that climbs
uh it's it's a tradition that seems to
be fading out a little bit in today
one of the legendary rangers that
spanned the time period from the 1930s
to the 1970s was manuel trezas gonzalez
as the name might suggest
lone wolf as he was called gonzales
was born of canadian and portuguese
parents he immigrated to mexico became
an officer in the mexican army decided
he would immigrate to the united states
immigrated to texas
wound up joining the texas rangers and
became a legend in the east texas oil
fields of the 1930s restoring law and
order
gonzalez later went on to set up the
first crime lab that the texas rangers
and texas department of public safety
ever had and then after retirement
became a consultant to the movie and
television industry for programs like
tales of the texas rangers
we have a lot of his personal artifacts
he was one of the few old-time rangers
to live to see this museum and a hall of
fame founded
and
it's pretty amazing one of the
interesting stories about gonzalez is
when he was in the oil fields he was
being followed by a bunch of criminals
that really wanted him out of the way
and they'd follow his car and try to
bump him off the road and everything
else he said i've had enough of that so
he rigged his car out with a thompson
submachine gun in the trunk and one
beside him pointing forward
by the driver's seat
and when they came up he popped a wire
which raised the trunk and exposed the
machine gun in the back and the drive
people driving toward him saw the
thompson pointing at them from the front
seat and he didn't have too many other
problems but we have one of his thompson
submachine guns and a photograph of the
car that shows how uh how he had it
rigged up but he was really a legendary
ranger who spanned everything from the
horse and buggy days all the way to
modern
forensic criminology
we
are fortunate in having a large
collection of materials related to
bonnie and clyde the famous
desperados that have shown up in movies
and television and everything else the
real story of bonnie and clyde is often
a lot different than what you see in
movies and
televisions clyde barrow was a minor
criminal who started out in the 1930s
with such
exotic crimes as chicken theft and
things like that wound up getting sent
to the state prison in huntsville
where he
managed to upgrade his criminal skills
he hooked up with a waitress from west
dallas bonnie parker and they started a
criminal spree uh centering around 1934
that carried them through about a half a
dozen to a dozen states in the u.s
their career took a down
uh spy downward spiral when they decided
to break into the state prison and break
out one of their gang members and
managed to shoot to death one of the one
of the prison guards in the process
the prison system went to a retired
ranger frank hamer pulled him out of
retirement gave him a special commission
with the prison system and he tracked
bonnie and clyde for over a hundred days
he found out where they were who their
relatives were what their personal
habits were and that sort of thing
convinced the family that they were
probably going to be pulled in as
accessories unless they got bonnie and
clyde off the
off the path that they were on
and found out through an informant where
they were going to be they set up an
ambush in western louisiana that ended
bonnie and cro body and clyde's career
this is a pocket watch that belonged to
clyde barrow when he was incarcerated
one time
the pocket watch was taken away from him
bonnie parker broke it uh didn't break
him but went in to visit him in the jail
with a pistol secret it broke him out of
the jail and he left the pocket watch
behind but this is uh
this is one of the more interesting
bonnie and clyde artifacts that we have
one of the things we do at the museum is
not only deal with the real texas
rangers but we deal with the texarang
texas rangers of american pop culture if
you look at motion pictures there are
over 200 motion pictures that have been
made since 1910 with a major character
being a texas ranger in the movie and it
doesn't show any sign of abating
the
rangers of course first appeared in
literature and some of these were novels
that started out in the 1840s to the
1890s all over the world
we have examples that are printed in
lange languages such as dutch and
japanese
and italian and that sort of thing in
the 1930s and 40s the uh
one of the things that existed alongside
comic books were called pulp magazines
and these were basically monthly novels
that were issued
and you had such things as the texas
ranger pulp magazines that came out and
we have complete runs of a lot of these
today you see things such as the italian
version of a comic book down here which
has been in production in italy since
the 1940s
and we have a belgian next to it we have
a belgian children's book suskie and
whiskey the texas rangers that
was very was very popular at that point
in time
just literally thousands and thousands
of them we can't even keep up with them
one of our real treasures at the museum
is some material directly connected with
clayton moore who was the famous
television lone ranger for so many years
we have one of the masks that he had
made each time that they would start a
new season's production he would have a
number of masks made and then pick out
the most comfortable ones to wear well
there are only a handful of these that
still survive to these days
thanks to a
collector
dr taylor who lived up in montana who
collected lone ranger material for about
50 years we have a huge collection of
this material including one of the masks
and clayton moore had a gun belt made
for her he had his own gun belts made
and presented it to her
that is the identical to the ones that
were used in the television productions
and the movie productions and that sort
of thing the pistols are replicas but
the gun the gun belt is original and
then we have one of the hats that was
that was produced for him to wear in the
in the tv series but this material are
things that are actually tied directly
to the production of the lone ranger and
we're just delighted to have them the
texas rangers really seem to have fired
people's imaginations uh since the 1840s
they have been a part of american
culture both as a pop culture item and a
real thing
the reason the museum exists is to
kind of perpetuate the heritage that the
rangers bring to us you know it's it's
sort of like gary cooper's high noon
they are regarded as the few people
taking on overwhelming odds and the you
know and the
cause of what is right and just and
should be done
people come here to the texas ranger
hall of fame and museum because they
want to
see see the pieces of this history to
kind of immerse themselves in it and
there's always a chance since we have a
texas ranger company on site here that
they can meet a real live texas ranger
which is what a lot of them would like
to do
all weekend long american history tv is
joining our time warner cable partners
to showcase the history of waco texas
conversation like us on facebook at
c-span history
up next on american history tv larry
wood author of ozarks gunfights and
other notorious incidents shares the
area's violent history
he talks about feuding groups and
infamous criminals from wild bill hickok
to bonnie and clyde
the kansas city public library hosted
this event
first of all i want to thank jeremy and
the staff here at the library for
inviting me
thank all of you for turning out and i
guess we need to thank c-span for being
here also
as jeremy said the main book i'm going
to be talking about is ozarks gunfights
and other notorious incidents he also
mentioned desperados of the ozarks which
is kind of a follow-up to this book but
i probably will not have time to get to
it much but i will have copies of both
both books for anyone who's interested
in them
ozarks gunfights and other notorious
incidents as the name suggests is about
murders and
shootouts and anything notorious that
happened in the ozarks in some cases
slightly outside the ozarks and the time
frame is from the end of the civil war
up through the gangster era of the 20s
and 30s uh with one exception that the
very last uh story is about something
that happened in 1950 but mainly it
covers the old west era and the gangster
era
and i might say
other than those connecting threads if
there's any other
theme that i try to develop in the story
it's kind of the one that i talk about
in the preface and that is something
jeremy also touched on
the idea that the old west was not just
kansas and arizona territory and places
like that particularly in the years
immediately uh immediately after the
civil war like from 1865 to 1875
1880 there was a lot of stuff
that happened in missouri and the ozarks
and we were very much a part of the old
west wild west i would say
the first chapter in my book is about uh
wild bill hickok particularly his
shootout on the square in springfield
with dave tutt
uh hickok was born in illinois came uh
west when he was about 18 years old in
1857 spent time in kansas and other
places at the time of the civil war he
was working as a stock uh handler
at a
kind of a waste station along the oregon
trail near what's now in beatrice
nebraska
i think the name of the place was rock
creek he got involved in a shootout with
the mccandless gang when dave mccandless
the previous owner of this
property that the stage
waste station was on came to try to
collect the debt collect the payment on
his property and end up in a shootout
and mccandless and at least one or other
one or two other people ended up getting
killed
later on
bill hooked on
with the union army at sedalia missouri
as a wagon master or wagon driver
and he eventually ended up in
springfield as a
detective for the union army sometimes a
spy sometimes
a
scout through the territory of southwest
missouri
but anyway this is a picture of the
square of springfield at about the time
that he was there this is from circa
1865.
we're looking south east
to into the southeast corner of the
springfield square the little building
in the very southeast corner was a
saloon owned by a guy named andrews
one of the things that wild bill did
when he was detective a union policeman
in springfield
was he arrested
andrews for illegally selling booze to
union soldiers you know they had
restrictions on how much you could how
much if any you could sell he
what i don't remember exactly what he
was cited for but that was one of the
things that wild bill did was arrest
andrews
toward the
middle part or maybe a little bit toward
the latter part of the civil war
probably like late 1863 early 1864
uh bill
and dave tut hooked up and became
friends there's some talk that they
might have already known each other
slightly but anyway they hooked up in
springfield became friends became a
drug buddies and and
gambling buddies but they had a falling
out near the end of the civil war and
the falling out was over a gambling debt
that
dave tut said that hickok owed him
and they disagreed on the amount uh tut
said that it was 35 hickok said it was
only 25
uh
and they were in a
hotel room in at the line hotel which is
just was about a block south of the
public square
and it was an afternoon poker game
and
the end the poker game ended
and
tut reminded him of the debt that he
owed him and
while bill was going to dig through his
pockets and show him the memorandum to
prove that it was only 25
and then digging through his pockets he
digged out his uh
gold waffen pocket watch and laid it on
the table
and
picked it up and said well i will keep
that for collateral and while bill says
well don't wear it in public
and touch that i'll wear it across the
square if i want to
and so later on that evening while bill
took up a station down at the square at
one of the intersections waiting to see
whether tut would carry through with his
uh warning that he was going to walk
across the square carrying the the
disputed
cl
watch sure enough he did
and while bill stepped out to meet him
and they both drew their guns about the
same time
and while bill hit tut but tutt missed
while bill
this was supposedly the first
what was called a wild west shootout of
the old
of the wild west era in other words it
was the first time that they didn't use
uh formal dueling when they had a
dispute they just went went out there
and had a spontaneous gun fight so this
was kind of uh is remembered as the
first wild west gun fight
and that of course is a depiction from
harper's
new monthly magazine of the card game
this is a depiction of the gun fight
itself
you can't really tell much about that
but that's uh that's not exactly how it
happened i mean for one thing they were
a lot farther apart than it seems to
appear there
they were like 75 yards apart
this picture
i took myself this is not a modern this
is maybe 10 years old but this is
somewhat what springfield square looks
like today it's not like i said it's not
real up to date but i took the picture
and
i was standing they had a plaque they
have plaques in the
uh
road showing where each man was standing
and i was standing about where while
bill was standing supposed to have been
standing when he took his picture and
actually it's kind of off
it would be off in here somewhere and
this building there
is where the courthouse at the time
stood
and dave tut was just outside the
entryway of the courthouse so it was
like from there across to there but it
was actually a
little farther back my
subsequent research has led me to
believe very strongly that uh hiccup was
really farther over this way to the
southwest so it was more like here down
to there you know it was about 75 yards
apart when they shot at each other
anyway bill hickok was arrested and was
going to be prosecuted for manslaughter
uh dave tut was buried in what was then
the city cemetery just a couple blocks
off of springfield later he was
that
tombstone there on the right is is
probably the one that
was placed when he was moved from the
city cemetery to where he is now
the uh maple park cemetery about three
or four blocks south of the square and
then that modern one was just hadn't
been there all that long just maybe 50
20 50 years or so i don't know how long
exactly
but uh anyway the interesting thing
about uh
some of the many of these episodes
is that they had uh overtones left over
from the civil war in this case
the fight between hickok and tut really
did not because they were friends even
though uh tut was a former confederate
soldier and
hickok was a
i mean former confederate soldier and
hickok was a federal they still were
friends so that really didn't enter into
it but what did enter into it was when
hickok went to trial on for manslaughter
they had what was called the drake
constitution that was passed right at
the end of the civil war in missouri
which said that anyone who had ever
supported the confederacy could not vote
could not hold office could not you know
be a preacher be a teacher all sorts of
things so naturally all the
jurors and all the officers of the court
were union people and hickok was a union
person so he got he got off you know a
lot of the confederate people thought
that he was to blame because he had
actually gone down to the corner and
just waited on you know just waiting to
see whether the guy would come across
there you know he was kind of stalking
him almost
another episode that really did have a
lot of overtones from the civil war was
the killing of a
preacher in
webster county it was just right across
the county line from greene county
springfield of course is greene county
webster county is the next county east
one of the
this headley guy samuel headley was a
preacher of the
methodist episcopal church south
and he preached a lot at pleasant view
which was a church right across the
county line in webster county
but during the civil war
as the north more and more took charge
that church was taken over by the
methodist episcopal church north
then at the end of the civil war about a
year later in in july of 1866
hedley despite the fact that he had not
taken the
uh oath of oath of allegiance like the
drake constitution said you had to
he decided he was going to try to
reclaim that church for the southern
wing of the church and he announced when
he was going to do it and he was going
to preach there and they warned him not
to but he showed up and did it anyway
and they killed him
and
this is really all that's left of the
church that was there at the time is
just the cemetery and
this is what they call the new
pleasantview church it was built around
1904 1903 that's the new pleasantview
church but anyway
uh
both the guy that shot headley and the
guy that had warned him not to come you
know and had been kind of the organizer
of the ones that was opposing him uh
ended up going on trial for murder but
they were both
again they were both acquitted because
you know they were they were northerners
this is a picture of grant granby
missouri it's a probably around turn of
the century it's it's not right after
the civil war as you can see there's
there's light polar you know telephone
poles or light poles or something so
it's probably more like around 1900 but
it'll give you a taste of what granby
looked like back in the old days
granby is in newton county it's probably
one of the most notorious little towns
in the united states in the years
immediately after the civil war i don't
know of any other
town
of a similar population that produced as
many notorious characters as granby
missouri did not a lot of them haven't
never heard of but they were notorious
people uh i'll be talking about at least
one or two of them my other book
desperados also talks about some of them
one of them was a guy named
i've gone a little too far here but i'll
get to her i'll get to her
i'll get to her in a minute uh
one guy was named jake killian and what
jake killian did was he went to a
traveling circus
there in granby that william lake owned
and it was a double feature
and you could stay for the first one but
then you had to get out and pay to come
back in to get to the second one well he
tried to hide so that he wouldn't have
to pay for both ties he was hiding under
a chair but william lake and some of his
lakes helpers found him and forcefully
put him out and that made him mad and he
went home and got a gun came back and
killed william lake
well now where she comes in is that's
william lake's widow uh agnes
thatcher lake and she put up a a
reward for you know arrest of jake kelly
and and another thing that's interesting
about her is she later married while
bill hickok i mean not not later from
this picture but later from after she
after lake was killed this picture was
taken probably maybe even after a while
bill hickok was killed but you know she
married while bill after her first
husband
was killed
and anyway jake kelly himself then ended
up getting killed in 1878 in galena
kansas
uh by a man named norton and they had
been sworn enemies ever since the civil
war they had been
soldiers together in the northern army
and gotten into an argument over a card
fight and norton had
partially blinded uh killing in one eye
but was shooting kind of shot his eye
out or almost out and
killing had sworn vengeance so when he
got out of jail after killing lake he
got out on probation he went looking for
uh
for
norton found him at
galena
and as soon as
norton saw him coming he just pulled he
got out and shot him just shot kill
didn't give killing a chance
but he still got off because of the fact
that killian had been stalking him you
know and had been been coming after him
so but notice the killing family said
that
he was murdered you know
this is the bender family not actually
in the ozarks a little outside the
ozarks i said there's a couple of the
stories in here that are not
really ozarks but they're close enough
the benders ran a wayside inn near
cherryvale kansas in the early 1870s
it consisted of john bender his wife a
son named whose name was also john and a
daughter named kate kate was the only
one that spoke fluent
english there was a german family she
spoke fluent english and was considered
kind of the leading spirit of the
family she was a spiritual healer you
know she
told people that she was a healer and
spiritualist
uh but anyway what this family
did was they ran away side in
and people started disappearing when
around you know they'd be traveling
along the road and then they would never
reach their destination and finally
people started getting suspicious that
maybe it had something to do with these
bender people and in the spring of 1873
a man named york
went missing and his brother
followed him to the bender house and
asked questions and
didn't got some kind of suspicious
answers so he went back to organize a
policy but by the time he got back with
the posse vendors had had flown had fled
and anyway so they put out a reward for
him this was a governor signing a
proclamation offering a reward for the
vendors
describing them and
so forth and how much money was offered
uh this is a picture of the house where
where they finally when they finally
started investigating there at the
bender house they dug up like 10 or 11
bodies the people that they had killed
apparently they would get it they had
the house partitioned off and they would
arrange it where the traveler would be
sitting with his back to the partition
and someone from the other side of the
partition would conk him over the head
with a hammer or something then they'd
finish him off with a knife or whatever
and
drop his body through a trap door and
then drag him out and hang him
but anyway they killed like i say half a
dozen or more probably more like 10 or
12 people
and this is a what used to be a
historical marker i'm not sure it's even
still there if it's not there's one very
similar to it that's still there uh
close to where it happened uh close to
cherryvale it kind of describes it and
notice down at the very last
last
paragraph it says although stories
abound the ultimate fate of the
murderous bender family is uncertain
some some say they escaped others that
they were executed by the vengeful posse
their story is unresolved and remains
one of the greatest unsolved mysteries
of the old west
i am one of those who is absolutely
convinced that
they were executed by the vengeful
policy because the vengeful policy went
after them
and came back several days later and
absolutely would not talk about it would
not say anything what what what happened
well why would you not talk about it
because you thought don't want people to
know you took the law in your own hands
you know and don't want to have to be
you know prosecuted for that not only
that
i've gone through enough papers later on
year you know 10 15 20 years later i've
run onto two or three or four
men
a couple of them on their deathbed who
says they were members of that posse and
sure enough that's what happened we
overtook them and killed them you know
so so i don't think
that i don't think they escaped
this is a picture of jim younger the
infamous younger gang
in
1874 they pulled off the gads hill the
james younger gang pulled off the
gadgets hill train robbery way over in
wayne county eastern part of missouri
came back and took refuge the james
brothers took refuge in their home
stomping grounds of clay county the
youngers took refuge in
osceola whatever county that is saint
clara county
around monogal springs because that's
where their grandfather had lived and
where they'd spent a lot of time with
the kids and that was kind of their
holdup
and two
pinkerton detectives came in looking
into the territory looking for them
and they brought along a local
uh deputy from osceola
and they found them or they knocked at
the home of a man named snuffer who was
an old friend of the grandfather
and sure enough the
youngers were there but they were hidden
in upstairs attic and so they they went
on their way and after they had left the
youngers followed them and caught up
with them just about a half a mile away
and overtook them and had a gunfight
and
john younger was killed uh jim younger
was injured slightly
one of the
pinkerton detectives was killed and the
local deputy sheriff was killed the only
one that got away unscathed was the
second
pinkerton deputy and anyway this is a
headstone or kind of a monument about it
that sets a little ways away from where
it actually happened this is the
original monument that sets very close
to where it happened
uh
it's fairly close about two miles north
of roscoe that's why it's called the
roscoe gunfight uh they run on their way
to montego springs is
about two or three miles nor uh north of
where that is
but anyway so
next chapter concerning something i
mentioned galena kansas while ago this
is a picture of galena kansas around the
turn of the century again you can see
light post so you know it's not 1870s or
whatever for probably around 1900 but it
shows you that galena was really a
hopping place you know around the
turn of the century and even earlier it
was a wild place it was a mining town
like a lot of mining towns you know
there was a lot of young
single man and anywhere there's a lot of
young single men mining and stuff
there's going to be a lot of wild
drinking and gun play and that sort of
thing and that was kind of galena's
reputation
one of the things that happened in
galena
uh in the fall of 79 1879 was supposedly
jesse james got killed by george
shepherd
supposedly
uh
that's
jesse james george shepard of course had
been a former member of the james gang
but he had kind of had a falling out
with
frank and jesse and he had uh
offered his services to the law and they
they said okay so he infiltrated the
gang with the intention of trying to
either kill or or capture jesse james
and after the
glendale train robbery which took place
here in jackson county i think somewhere
i don't know where exactly where
glendale is i think it's part of
independence now maybe or something but
after the glendale train robbery they
were going south to texas to spend the
winter this was in november of 1879.
they got a little bit south of galena
and some kind of
confrontation occurred don't know
exactly what it was but george shepherd
went riding back into galena with a
bloody mangled
leg saying that i've killed jesse james
i just killed jesse james
and the newspapers the next they went
out and investigated couldn't find any
dead bodies in the newspapers the next
day said either
george sheppard lies
living or or jesse james lies dead and
well most people mostly most people
believe that it was george sheppard
lying living you know
but my own personal belief is that
something actually did happen and i
think maybe george thought he actually
had killed him you know he probably did
shoot at him and he might have even seen
him fall out of his saddle or something
you know but it didn't kill him and
obviously because he was killed later on
a couple two three years later in saint
joseph
uh that's george sheppard a picture of
him anyway
uh
ball knobbers
were a vigilante group down in taney
county missouri that's south of
springfield
that rose up around 1883 they call
themselves the law and order group or
sometimes call themselves the
citizens committee something like that
because they considered themselves kind
of a
an okay group you know a honorable group
and then they kind of started out that
way the way a lot of vigilante groups do
that they're trying to do something good
but of course they went overboard the
reason they were called ball knobbers is
because this was where their first
organizational meeting was held it was
on a ball knob you know out
close to foresight
and this was the leader nat kinney
nathaniel kenny
when this picture was taken he was a
saloon keeper in springfield
but he shortly after this he moved down
in taney county and became preacher
started preaching at a church
and i guess started laying off the booze
i don't know or her
but anyway
uh
again i've talked about how some of the
incidents were
kind of carry over or at least the
bitterness from the civil war kind of
carried over to
aggravate some of these incidents that's
the case even with the uh ball knobbers
which is 20 years after the civil war
because almost all of the ball knobbers
were former northern soldiers
and a group that rose up to oppose them
the anti-ball knobbers were almost all
former confederate soldiers you know so
there again there was overtones from the
civil war but uh
the ball knobbers and the
anti-ballnabbers kind of killed each
other a couple a couple of members of
each but as far as the law ever taking
any active role in trying to apprehend
them none of them really were ever
apprehended however the baldner movement
moved over into christian county
a couple years later like in the mid
1880s
and there the law did get it to get into
it this is billy walker who was the son
of the leader of the christian county
faction the his father's name was
dave dave walker
and another one of the main ones was
john matthews and he had a nephew named
wiley matthews all four of them were
eventually captured
and tried for murder because they'd
killed a couple people of a family over
by chadwick
and
they were
convicted and scheduled to hang but
wiley this man's nephew escaped and was
never recaptured so actually only three
of them hanged on the square in ozark
like in 1888 and that was kind of the
end of ball noborism after that
this is a picture a replica picture of
what one of the christian county uh
masks they had masks they had the kind
of secret signs secret codes and so
forth
this is a picture of emma molloy not
this is a better picture ever here when
she was younger that you can tell she
was a an attractive looking woman but
anyway
emma molloy was a nationally known
uh temper temperance revivalist she
traveled all over the country giving
revivals trying to get people to you
know not drink
and she gave one in springfield missouri
in the winter of 1884-85
and after it was over with she moved out
onto a farm
west of springfield near brookline
and she had
a
adopted
adopted daughter
a
foster daughter named coralie
and maybe one or two other people living
with her she was always taking people in
trying to help them you know and that
was her downfall because
she had taken in this guy named george
graham
whom she had first met in indiana prison
when she was doing prison ministry and
she had kind of taken him under her wing
and after he got out
they went into
the uh business together of putting out
this uh
you know anti-drinking the
anti-drinking newspaper the
what's the word i said well ago temper
the temperance newspaper uh
and so pretty soon after they started
living on the brookline farm he showed
up
and started uh romancing coralie the the
uh foster daughter
actually he resumed uh
courting her because they had already
started when they were back together in
washington kansas putting out this uh
paper they had gone into cooch putting
out the temperance paper and then when
she moved to springfield he kind of
followed him there and resumed the
romance eventually he talked him into
letting to let him get married they were
concerned because they knew he had been
married before to sarah graham but he
assured him that
he
had divorced her when she or that she
had divorced him when he went to jail
well that was true but it turned out
that they had remarried after he got out
so he was committing bigamy when he
married
coralie
well things went along okay for a little
while but then sarah graham came to try
to get her kids you know
they had a couple of kids sarah and
george did
and
when george realized he was going to be
found out with about his bigamy he
committed a graver crime to try to cover
up the bigamy he killed his first wife
sarah graham dumped her in a well on the
malloy farm
and that's what this headline is talking
about
uh
cora lee was arrested he was of course
arrested for murder uh when they finally
found out cora was arrested as an
accessory before the fact because they
thought she was kind of in cahoots with
it emma molloy was arrested as a after
the fact accessory after the fact
because they thought she kind of helped
cover up she was not present when it
happened but they thought after she got
back from her revival that she found out
about it and tried to help cover it up
and these are some of the pictures of
the people
principles in it this is george graham
these are all just sketches he was the
exorcist side in other words wife killer
one that killed his wife
this is coralie the uh
the uh
foster daughter that he married
bigamously
and this is sarah graham the one the
first wife that he murdered
and this is sarah and
and george's son charlie their oldest
son and he figured prominently in the
legal proceedings
george of course was like i said was
arrested for murder
but actually coralie's trial started
taking place before george's and she was
being tried for being an accessory and
he was the
one that turned it into a sensational
thing because he testified that not only
had he seen cora and
george his father and cora in bed
together at washington kansas at one
time he had also seen him his father in
bed with emma malloy at one time not
only that he had seen him both in bed at
the same time with his father you know
so i mean he was he made he turned it
into really a scandalous thing now you
know it may have been that they were
sitting on the edge of the bed i don't
know you know
back then
he didn't say that he saw him having
sexual intercourse you know he just said
they so i don't know what it was but
anyway he uh he turned it in they really
you know they liked the scandal back in
those days so
uh
anyway and it was so it's such a
scandalous deal that the springfield
newspapers even put out a special
edition of kind of a
big whole thick pamphlet having to do
with nothing but the the graham tragedy
and the and the examination of uh
malloy and lee
anyway while cora's
trial was still going on george graham
was taken from jail by mob and lynched
in springfield
and then eventually
coralie's trial was ended in a hung jury
and when that happened they just dropped
all the charges against emma malloy uh
coralie had to be tried at least twice i
can't remember exactly how many times
but anyway
my own take on it is
that uh i think
emma malloy was
kind of rash not very
was not very uh
judicial in deciding who she was going
to be friends she like i said she was
always taking people in and playing the
the part of the goody goody wanting to
help people i think that was her main
her main mistake she just you know uh
coralie i don't know for sure about her
but
another kind of a similar type deal
where it was involved a triangle or
whatever uh
there was a guy named jj white and
he had a friend named ed klum c-l-u-m
they were they lived in new york they
had been in the union army together in
new york
uh
klum was married got married to this
girl named charlotte they called her
lottie
and j.j white decided he kind of liked
her too and started flirting with her
and they started kind of having an
affair
and
lottie was not in real good health so
she
decided she was going to come to
missouri to stay with her sister at
lebanon missouri
and not too long after that white came
to missouri and bought a farm at pierce
city in berry county that's
down close to where casseville is
and
instead of staying at the 11 11 and with
her sister though she came on and
started living with j.j white at the
farm
uh klim got word of it and came down to
investigate
but in order to protect his wife's
name he let them introduce him as her
brother instead of her husband you know
and they he there are people around
pierce city thought that that's what
they were
finally he convinced her to go back with
him and he got as far as lebanon and she
said she really didn't feel like
continuing the trip that she would stop
at lebanon and she would come on the
next day but instead she went back to
spare city when he while he was going
bonds at rochester new york this
happened
once or twice maybe maybe at least twice
uh finally
he got word he was back in new york he
got word that lottie had died so he came
back he came back and even after lottie
was dead he still
let people believe that he and lottie
had been brother sister not husband and
wife you know and this went on for a few
more months and it was 1886
finally jj there was this 17 year old
girl who had been a housekeeper started
being keeping house in the clum
residence or the white residence
and she and white announced their
intention to get married well klum kind
of had a crush on her too so that that
was that was the camp this you know the
the
straw that broke the camel's back he
ended up killing both of them
yeah they said if he had if he had done
it
if he had killed
uh white back earlier he probably would
have gotten away with it but he by
killing that 17 year old innocent girl
this is her grave uh at pierce city
uh by killing the innocent girl he ended
up getting sentenced to hang and this is
his
execution date in cassville in 1887.
uh
this is one of the banks in coffeyville
that the dalton gang tried to hold up
they you know the daltons were
cousins of the youngers and so they were
going to try to outdo their infamous
more infamous uh older cousins by
robbing two banks at the same time
and they were they tried to rob two
banks at the same time in the fall of
1892 in coffeyville kansas
uh the problem they had they had lived
in coffeeville previously and they
thought they knew the place but the
problem was when they got there the
hitching rail where they were going to
hitch their horses was no longer there
so they had to hitch a horses somewhere
different that was farther away from the
bank you know
and that ended up being their downfall
but anyway
anyway the citizens of coffeyville armed
realized what was going on and armed
themselves and had a big shootout with
them and four of the
dalton members got killed none of the
citizens got killed there's the four
dalton they laid them out and took
pictures of them
and then there they buried them right
there in coffeyville uh
for
bob dalton grant dalton
and then a couple others
bill power then one of them they didn't
bear there's one they buried somewhere
else
anyway but rightfully so they call their
they have a little museum in in
coffeeville they don't call it the
dalton museum they call it the dalton
defenders museum because they want
they want to emphasize that they're
memorializing the defenders not the not
the crooks you know
after the dalton gang uh
you know was shot to pieces and
disintegrated uh bill doolin who had
previously ridden briefly with the
dalton gang kind of picked up the pieces
and started his own gang from the
remnants of the of the dalton gang it's
called the
the
the duelins uh
uh he had a name for it i don't anyway
dueling gang
and
in
1894 just less than two years after the
coffeeville deal he tried to rob a bank
in uh
southwest city that's the very farthest
you can get in southwest missouri it's
called southwest city a little town it's
right in the corner of the of the
oklahoma and arkansas
and this is the what was the bank at
that time it's still there obviously
it's no longer used as a bank but that's
the same building that they tried to rob
and it turned out almost to be a kind of
a reenactment of the fiasco at
coffeeville because the citizens armed
themselves and started shooting opposing
it but in this case the citizens got the
worst of it
one of the citizens got killed
and
the couple of the outlaws got scratched
you know minor injuries but not serious
injuries
and that's the road they came in this is
the current picture of southwest city
the road they came in on
and then this year or so later bill
dewan did eventually get killed by a
lawman but not not as a direct result of
of the
of the southwest city deal this was
like i said a year or so later he got
killed by heck thomas i think it was
i mentioned galena kansas while ago
another notorious episode that happened
in galenas kansas happened in 1897.
they found this guy named frank
galbraith in a his body stuffed in a an
abandoned
mine lead mine
galena was a big mining town
and come to find out they
thought they arrested
the staffel back gang the problem was
that galbraith had gone to the stop
staple bath house late at night it was
kind of
known as a house of ill repute and he
had gone there wanting to see a certain
woman and it's two o'clock in the
morning and they said it was too late
they didn't want they wouldn't let her
come out and he kept on insisting so
finally they got mad at him and i guess
killed him and dumped him in a and uh
but anyway
the the media then got a hold of this
and they started exaggerating it
you can see here it says for years they
have plied their work of death you know
and they they thought that they'd killed
like you know as many as 10 12 people
but frank galbraith's body was the only
one that was ever found you know so that
was probably just a lot of exaggeration
uh this was old lady stapleback named
nancy she was supposedly the leading
spirit of it the one that had gave him
given the
ordered to kill that guy
uh but anyway they have a house in
galena now that they call the
staffordback house
another
notorious episode episode involving a
woman was cora hubbard she and two male
sidekicks held up the bank of pineville
later in 1897
these were other two sidekicks one in
the middle is whit tennyson one on the
right is
john sheets
they hooked up in
kansas
around
somewhere in southeast kansas and they
they plotted it and planned it out but
then they rode all the way to southwest
city to pull it off and they came back
to kansas and they were arrested in
kansas near their hometown in kansas
and taken back to
pineville for arraignment eventually
tried
they received
10
varying terms in the prison anywhere
from 10 to 12 years in prison
each one of them did but anyway she was
called the the
new best or the second bell star or
something like that so again it was
sensationalized simply because she was a
woman you know they they turned her into
kind of a heat not almost a hero but
bell star type person
now i'm jumping from
the old west i guess you might say to
the gangster era uh this is henry starr
he started out in the old west area he
was a outlaw you know he was a bell
star's nephew by marriage uh he was a
big bank robber and train robber during
the old west era but then he graduated
from fast horses to fast cars in the 19
teens and around in there and started
robbing banks
and
the one that i talk about mainly in my
book well two r he robbed the
bentonville bank in like
1893 or not that was before cars but
then the one with cars that i talk about
most is when he tried to rob the bank of
harrison arkansas
uh in
[Music]
like february of 1921
and he ended up getting killed
and that's the man that killed him he
was the former president he he was the
former president of the bank he just
happened to be there on the day that
this happened
but he was the former president and he
knew where there was a gun stashed and
he grabbed the gun and killed him
and that's
henry starr after he was laid out
dead and then a year or so later after
this in the fall of 1922 like about a
year and a half later the remnants of
the star gang tried to hold up the
eureka springs arkansas bank and again
the
uh citizens armed themselves and killed
like two and seriously injured a third
member of the gang
uh and this was them after the thing was
all over they were celebrating the fact
that they had you know broken up the
bank robbery and and captured or killed
all the bank robbers
and that's one of the one the one they
killed one of the ones they killed
another guy whose career also spanned
the wild west era as well as the the
gangster era was uh roy dougherty his
nickname was arkansas tom
he was born in barry
berry county missouri
that's again that's where casseville is
uh but he drifted into oklahoma and
hooked up with the wild bunch that was
what the name i was trying to think of a
while ago bill doolin's wild bunch
and
they pulled off the the shootout at
ingles and the only one that was
captured was him was roy dougherty all
the rest of the gang got away
he was captured sent to prison for 50
years
but after about 20 or so he got paroled
in the 19 teens and then he like same
way as as uh star as henry starr
graduated to bank robbery on automobiles
he robbed this uh bank in oronogo
missouri that's just north of the webb
city or north of joplin the funny thing
about this is
our ironic thing is about 15 20 years
later bonnie clyde also robbed this very
same very same bank
and then in the early 1920s uh roy
dougherty robbed the asbury bank which
is kind of northwest of uh
joplin between between joplin and
pittsburgh kansas
and while he was still on the land for
this this was like in 1922
and a couple less than two years later
in 1924 they finally tracked him down in
joplin at this house his house has been
remodeled but it's still the same house
and he was killed in this house by
joplin police in 1924 buried in an
unmarked grave in fairview cemetery in
spring or not in springfield in joplin
this is uh maul barker uh maul barker
was born in ashe grove missouri it looks
that's close to springfield her kids
were mainly born around aurora missouri
that's where monet is around in there
and then
when they were just little kids they
moved to webb city which is where joplin
is
and mainly grew up there and that's
where they first kind of started getting
into trouble not real serious trouble
but kind of kind of serious trouble so
she moved took him away to tulsa because
she didn't want to she thought by doing
so she could keep them out of trouble
well when they got to tulsa they just
got in more and more trouble
uh but anyway
after even after they moved to tulsa
they still kept coming back to missouri
and kind of using it as a hideout and
the old stomping grounds probably one of
the main things that they did in the
ozarks was when fred barker was our
youngest son and alvin karpas who was a
notorious gangster
killed the sheriff of howell county at
west plains missouri
west plains if you know missouri history
is way
kind of toward the east about 100 miles
east of springfield
but anyway that was probably the most
notorious uh thing that they did in the
ozarks and it's the first time when maul
barker was actually identified as a
member of the gang because in the house
where they they had been staying where
they found their papers and stuff they
found pictures of maulbarker and names
of all the gang members and stuff and so
that was when she first became notorious
really
and this is where the barkers are all
buried at welch oklahoma
this is a picture of
jennings
the jennings brothers uh
in
january of 1932
they killed six police officers from
springfield who came out to their house
near brookline that's just the lloyds
west of springfield there's like 10
police officers came out to capture them
there was just two of them two of the
jennings brothers and they thought well
you know this shouldn't be any problem
but what they didn't know is that the
jennings brothers had really high power
rifles while
the the cops only had pistols and anyway
six of them ended up getting killed and
even to this day is considered the
largest
uh most
law officers to lose their life in a
single shootout with with the outlaws
you know
and that's the house where it took place
that's their sisters
who helped them in
like
stealing cars but not help didn't help
them in the the murders
and this they were
also buried at joplin even though they
killed close to springfield they were
buried at joplin because springfield
wouldn't take them yeah
but joplin i guess they had so many
notorious characters buried there that
they went ahead and took them
okay
last chapter i'm going to talk about is
uh bonnie and clyde
uh bonnie and clyde of course was from
texas but they did a lot of their
notorious stuff in missouri and the
midwest throughout
in fact you guys may be familiar with
the one they did up here in platte city
they had a big shootout up there but the
one i'm mainly going to talk about is
the one in joplin
uh this was the place in joplin where
they holed up in april of 1933
uh the apartment was up above they
parked their cars
underneath the garage
and
they the local police first thought that
they weren't anything maybe possibly
bootleggers they didn't think they were
really serious criminals or anything but
they were going to check them out and so
they had four policemen in two separate
cars two or five policemen in two
separate cars three and one and two in
the other they pulled up there one of
the police cars pulled right up into the
driveway and
the that's when all hell broke loose
because the
clyde and his gang started shooting and
they finally jumped in one of their cars
and rammed the car that was parking the
police car that was parked blocking him
and knocked knocked him out of the way
so that they can make their escape in
the process they killed two police
officers
clyde was just slightly injured but
nobody else in
the gang was injured but as i say two
police officers were killed
uh
and the thing about the joplin shootout
was it was what really made bonnie and
clyde famous because they afterwards
they found two or three rows of
undeveloped film and and in the film a
lot of it was them just taking pictures
of themselves just kind of playful
posture you know pretending like one of
her
pretending to
be smoking a cigarette and a cigar and
posed up there
and then this one is uh wd jones the
young guy that was with them with all
his guns
and their
bonnie and clyde are playfully aiming
guns at each other
and there's clyde with his guns so
anyway these guns these pictures were
splashed all over the united states and
that's what really made them famous when
they started having pictures in in the
chicago
uh tribune and new york times and stuff
like that uh if those pictures had not
been retrieved from the joplin apartment
they might have just gone on being a not
you know not really well known
and this was a picture of bonnie
later on a few years late couple years
later after she was killed in louisiana
so anyway in closing i guess the thing
that i want to kind of re i already
touched on that i would kind of like to
reiterate is the idea that
the ozarks and all of missouri
particularly western missouri kansas
city and all along the western border we
were very much a part of the old west
during the especially in the first 10 or
15 years after the civil war and that
reputation for wildness continued clear
into the to the gangster era a lot of
the gangsters like i said the barker
gang even though they no longer lived in
missouri they continually came back to
missouri to to hide out and same thing
with bonnie and clyde they kind of
thought that this was a good place to
hide out
so we had more than our share not only
of wild west incidents but probably also
of
gangster type incidents and you guys
here all familiar with the
the one that uh jeremy mentioned about
the shootout at the uh
uh train or the
central south the central train station
yeah
so
any questions please
as jeremy said if you have questions
please line up and i'll be glad to
answer questions
if i can
let's first thank larry and then we'll
[Applause]
it's kind of kind of tall i do have a
question okay
uh guns belonging to bonnie and clyde
recently sold at auction for over a
quarter of a million dollars each over a
half a million dollars
how did those guns wind up in private
hands shouldn't they have been states
evidence
i honestly cannot answer that question i
don't i agree with you they probably
should have been states evidence but i i
do not know the answers to that i don't
know how they ended up in in private
hands
does anyone know how they ended up in
private hands
what
frank hammer one of the
he said that one of the officers the the
that was there when they killed him is
that what you're saying
yeah one of the one of the police
officers who were there when they killed
them and louisiana kept some of them
they just kept them they should be in
state's evidence they should have
belonged to the property
sometimes
sometimes states
are small or
the values will sell off
stuff years afterwards
thank you thanks
yeah back to the bender family you
mentioned that they killed 10 or 11
people i think they've dug up like 10 or
11 bodies yeah but is there was there a
motive is there speculation or what the
motive was the only the only motive
anyone could come up with was just greed
you know because they would
what they theorized that they were doing
was they would stop them you know the
travelers would stop there at the
wayside inn to get something to eat or
something to drink and they would kind
of position them you know i said they
had it kind of partitioned off and they
would position them with sitting at a
table with their back to the partition
and someone from the other side of the
partition would
put them out of commission with a hammer
or whatever and then they'd finish them
off with an eye for gun if they need be
but i don't think they wanted to use
guns because they didn't want you know
to raise the noise
and all they could figure out is they
were just robbing them you know they
were just taking whatever money little
money they might had you know
if only we had undeveloped rolls of film
for other gangsters of that era and had
pictures like that those were wonderful
pictures yeah larry i do have a question
uh you publish many books uh
your articles you know many articles
published on the ozarks in your your
blog ozarks history you regularly
publish articles there
some of these uh people are fairly well
known but others aren't and i i know
from your newspaper clippings that you
you get a lot of information from the
newspaper is there a library archives uh
is there kind of a a place where you do
most of your research or
now nowadays i do most of it online i i
subscribe to newspapers.com
which is a subscription service and it
entitles you to oh just all kinds of
newspapers from all across the country
uh and what i've run into like i've been
researching some pre-civil war stuff
that happened in missouri well in the
past that's been very hard to do because
most missouri newspapers before the
civil war are no longer in existence or
very few of them are but what i've
started finding out is i find something
published in the baltimore sun
you know repeating something that was
published in the st louis
globe or whatever in 1842 you know or or
something published in the new york
times that repeating something that was
published in maybe
a springfield newspaper or whatever you
know so you can find stuff that way you
know
i've heard that pendergast had a hunting
lodge in the ozarks uh near sedalia did
he do any of his shenanigans uh down
there or did he just keep him up here
i'm not too familiar with tom
i i have heard that though that he had
some kind of a hunting lodge somewhere
in the ozarks but i wasn't even for sure
where it was so you know more about and
i do my i have a brother who lives in
lakeview heights and it's supposed to be
in that town
larry this will be the last question one
of the audience members as was curious
how you became interested in uh ozarks
history okay uh
i was an english major in springfield i
was then smsu
and like a lot of english majors i kind
of aspired to be a writer but i wanted
to write fiction you know i thought i
was going to write the great american
novel
but as i wrote
you know over and over i found myself
having much more success at nonfiction
and i wrote a lot of
article magazine articles i found that i
could
if the
kind of the framework of the story was
already there
i could tell a really good story but as
far as coming up with creative ideas
myself i had more trouble with that so i
finally kind of gave up the idea of
writing the great american novel started
concentrating on non-fiction and then i
particularly started concentrating on
historical non-fiction
uh shortly after i started doing my own
genealogy research i guess you know
that's kind of what got me started in in
that field was i did my own history and
i just kind of wanted to branch out from
there you know so i started uh doing
local history that's been about probably
25 30 years ago
that i started branching out and doing
mostly history up until the i started
writing just straight out of college
pretty much so i've been writing about
almost 50 years but last
because i'm 70 years old now
so the last 25 at least i've been
concentrating on historical stuff
i would like to thank everyone for
coming out today and let's thank uh
and and i'd like to remind everyone that
he will have books for sale uh following
the problem i'll be setting up out there
and i'll talk to you some more if you
want to buy my book great if you're not
but not we can just talk i guess
interesting